PRESENT OR THE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA
ATKINS- BASE BECKER FORGES
BRADFORD CABRERO CORTESE DALLEY
DIED DURAZO EGGMAN GLAZER
CONSOLIDATES GROVE HERZBERG WAY
SO HER TADO JONES CAN LONGER
LAYERED LLEVA MCGUIRE MELINDA'S
MAN NEWMAN NIELSEN A SHOW OF
BOTH. HAN FORTUNE TINO ROSSI
RUBIO SKINNER AMBERG QUAKE
OWSKI WINNER WELL THANK YOU
MORE. A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH
THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY SENATOR
CAFIERO AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WHICH WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
BY SENATOR DOLLY. SEND A COPY
OF. TODAY'S PRAYER IS ABOUT
LEANING ON GOD. SOME PEOPLE
LEAN AGAINST FENCE POSTS WHEN
THEIR BODIES ACHE FROM TOIL.
SOME PEOPLE LEAN ON OAK TREES
SEEKING COOL SHADE ON HOT HUMID
DAYS. SOME PEOPLE LEAN ON
CRUTCHES WHEN THEIR LIMBS WON'T
WORK FOR THEM. SOME PEOPLE LEAN
ON EACH OTHER WHEN THEIR HEARTS
CAN'T STAND ALONE. KIND OF
SHELTER AND STRENGTH IT OFTEN
TAKES US A LONG TIME TO LEAN ON
YOU. WE PREFER TO REMAIN
INDEPENDENT RATHER THAN
ACKNOWLEDGE YOU AS AN OAK TREE
OF COMFORT. A STURDY SUPPORT
WHEN THE LIMBS OF OUR LIVES ARE
WEAK. PRAISE TO YOU ETERNALLY
INTO FOR BEING OUR REFUGE IN
DISTRESS FOR YOUR CONSTANT
PRESENCE. AND FOR CONTINUALLY
BRINGING A SLOW END TO THE WARS
WITHIN OUR HEARTS. AND IN OUR
WORLD AMEN. MEMBERS JOIN US IN
OUR PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. AND TO. TWO MEMBERS
TODAY WE HAVE SENATOR LA MON
AND STERN PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY GOOD MORNING SENATORS.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED RED
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED WE ARE
NOW MOVING ON MEMBERS TO
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
ARE THERE ANY MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS OR NOTICES. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING
RESOLUTIONS WILL BE PLACED ON
TODAY'S SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS SEVENTY SEVEN S.
C. R. TWENTY SIX. ITEM SEVENTY
EIGHT S. C. R. TWENTY SEVEN.
SING OBJECTION THANK YOU. SO WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE-
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
AND WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP
ITEM FIVE FIRSTS GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES. SENATOR LAYERED YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- THIS IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF A LIZABETH
LANDSBERG IS DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT. OF
PRIOR TO THIS ROLE SHE SERVED
AS DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE HELP
CENTER FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED CARE SHE HAS OVER
TWENTY YEARS EXPERIENCE AS A
HEALTH CONSUMER ADVOCATES
INCLUDING A DECADE WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. SHE WAS APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON MAY
FIFTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I THOUGHT. THANK YOU
SENATOR LET MEMBERS ARE THERE
IS THERE ANY- DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR PAN YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT-
SENATORS- HI TO. STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THE LIST WAS
LANDSBERG HAS- DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE STATE HEALTH PLANNING
DEVELOPMENT. CERTAINLY BRINGS A
DISTINGUISHED RECORD AS A
CONSUMER ADVOCATE AND HAD THE
CERTAINLY HE PLEASURE TO WORK
WITH HER. AND THAT AND- VARIOUS
ROLES IN THE PAST I DO WANT TO
JUST POINT OUT. TO THE SENATE
THOUGH THAT IN THIS PARTICULAR
DEPARTMENT. IS BEING PROPOSED
TO HAVE THAT. RATHER CHANCE
FROM- IT RATHER
TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE- SO
CERTAINLY IT PLAYS A VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE IN. MONITORING
HOSPITAL DATA AT OUR WORK FORCE
INTERRUPT BUT IS- IS IT. AN
OFFICE THAT'S BEING PROPOSED
TO. HAVE A VERY SUBSTANTIAL
ROLE AND- OVERSEEING- THE
HEALTHCARE SECTOR AND-
SPENDING. AND CERTAINLY WOULD
URGE JOB- DIRECTOR LANDSBERG TO
BE SURE THAT WE HAVE. THAT WE
HAVE LEADERSHIP IN THIS
DEPARTMENT THAT ACTUALLY AS IN
DEPTH KNOWLEDGE OF THE
HEALTHCARE. FIELD AND-
PARTICULARLY HEALTH ECONOMICS-
AS AS WELL AS A DEEP
UNDERSTANDING OF THE ROLE
PATIENTS HAVE INCLUDING-
PARTICULARLY PATIENTS WHO HAVE
CHRONIC CONDITIONS WHO
ACTUALLY. NEED HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO ENSURE THAT THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO THOSE SERVICES
AND THAT- THERE'S ADEQUATE
RESOURCES- FOR THOSE PARTICULAR
ADVOCATES THAT THOSE PATIENTS
SO CERTAINLY IN HER ROLE THE
PREVIOUS ROLE AS A CONSUMER
ADVOCATE I'M SURE SHE WILL BE
CHAMPIONING. THAT BUT-
CERTAINLY SUPPORT HER AT HER
APPOINTMENT- BUT THEY JUST WANT
TO- BRING UP- THE- CHANGING
ROLE OF THIS DEPARTMENT HOW
IMPORTANT THIS PARTICULAR
DEPARTMENT WILL BE. OUT TO
THOSE OF US WHO CARE ABOUT THE
HEALTH CARE OF OUR.
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU. C. NO
OTHER DAY. OR JUST. SIX PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA
HI ATKINS I BASE. BACKER FIVE
FOUR JUST. BRADFORD I HAVE I
GOTTA HI CORTESE HI DALLY NO
DODD. HI TORONTO HI ADNAN.
GLAZER. FIVE GONZALEZ FIVE
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG HI WITH SO
HI HER TADO HI JONES NO CAN
LONGER I LAYERED I LLEVA. FIVE
MCGUIRE. HI MELINDA'S NO MAN
FIVE NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A SHOW
OF VOGUE. PAN HI PORTS AND YOU
KNOW I. ROSS HI RUBIO. HI
SKINNER HI NUMBER ALL RIGHT HI
WHAT KIND OF SKI. HI WINNER. HI
WILKE. NO WE'LL CALL FOR JUST
NOW SINNER LED ME TO CALL THEM
OURS WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP SENATE
THIRD READING WE'RE GONNA MOVE
FIRST TO ITEM NINE FOLLOWED BY
THIRTEEN AND WE'VE GOT ABOUT A
DOZEN ITEMS YOU WANT TO GET
THROUGH TODAY- SO IF WE CAN. GO
TO. ONE ON ONE FIFTY ONE HELLO
I'M SORRY. THANK YOU WE ARE
FIRST WITHOUT OBJECTION GONNA
TAKE UP ITEM FIFTY ONE SENATE
PRO TEM ACTIONS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I RISE TO
INTRODUCE S. C. R. FORTY FOUR
RECOGNIZING THOSE INTERACTIONS
I APOLOGIZE MY BAD POLITICAL
REACH I NEED TO CLICK TO READ
PLEASE THANK YOU. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FORTY
FOUR BY SENATOR ATKINS RELATIVE
TO HOSPITAL WEEK. NOW THE
SOONER I CAN SAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO INTRODUCE
S. C. R. FORTY FOR RECOGNIZING
THE WEEK OF MAY NINTH TO MAY
FIFTEENTH IS NATIONAL HOSPITAL
WEEK. AS WE FIND OURSELVES
EMERGING FROM THE DARK TUNNEL
OF THE PANDEMIC ON THE PATH TO
BRIGHTER DAYS I KNOW THAT MANY
OF YOU SHARE THE SENSE OF
RELIEF AND OF PRIDE AND HOW
WELL OUR STATE IS DOING. WITH
SUPPRESSED CODED TRANSMISSIONS
THE LOWEST POSITIVITY RATE IN
THE NATION AND A GROWING
PERCENTAGE OF VACCINATED
RESIDENTS WE ARE SEEING GREAT
PROGRESS STILL OUR WORK IS FAR
FROM DONE COMMUNITIES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND OTHER DISENFRANCHISED
COMMUNITIES REQUIRE OUR
CONTINUED FOCUS. AND ATTENTION.
I'D LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE A
SECTOR OF THE HEALTHCARE
COMMUNITY THAT'S WORKING TO
SERVE THOSE COMMUNITIES. AND
THAT HAS WORKED TIRELESSLY TO
HELP OUR STAKE IT THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC AND THAT'S OUR
HOSPITALS. CALIFORNIA IS HOME
TO OVER FOUR HUNDRED HOSPITALS
WHICH TOGETHER PROVIDED CARE TO
OVER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PATIENTS WITH COPD AT NINETEEN.
PATIENTS THAT WERE OFTEN THE
SICKEST AND MOST VULNERABLE.
FACED WITH AN UNPRECEDENTED
PUBLIC HEALTH CHALLENGE OUR
HOSPITALS ROSE TO THE OCCASION.
THEY SUSPENDED NON ESSENTIAL
PROCEDURES THEY ACQUIRED MASS
QUANTITIES OF PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. I HARD TO
DIGITAL STAFF AND ESTABLISH NEW
WAYS TO MOVE IN CARE FOR
PATIENTS. THEY ADDED NEGATIVE
PRESSURE ROOMS TO ISOLATE COBIT
PATIENTS. THEY CONSTRUCTED
TEMPORARY STRUCTURES AND
PARKING LOTS AND CAFETERIAS
THEY LEAST CLOSED HOSPITALS%
CONVENTION CENTERS AND SPORTS
ARENAS. CREATED EMERGENCY
OPERATION CENTERS AND SO MUCH
MORE. AND BECAUSE THE LIFE DID
NOT PAUSE HOSPITALS KEPT THEIR
DOORS IN THEIR EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS OPEN TO CARE FOR
THOSE SUFFERING FROM HEART
ATTACKS. SERIOUS INJURIES AND
OTHER CRITICAL ILLNESSES.
HOSPITAL STAFF AND THEIR
ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO HAD
CONCERNS FOR THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THEIR OWN FAMILIES.
THEY STILL SHOWED UP FOR US.
AND LET ME ADD AS WE RECOGNIZE
HOSPITAL WEEK MAY SIXTH THROUGH
THE TWELFTH. WAS ACTUALLY
NATIONAL NURSES WEEK. AND AS
THE SISTER OF A NURSE IN THE
DAUGHTER IN LAW OF A NURSE I
WANT TO ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE THOSE
AEROBIC EFFORTS. WITH BETTER
DAYS AHEAD I WANT YOU TO JOIN
ME IN RECOGNIZING ALL OF THESE
THE ROIC EFFORTS DURING
NATIONAL HOSPITAL WEEK IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE I ASK FOR
YOUR I. LOVED. THANK YOU
SENATOR ATKINS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. WE HAVE
SENATOR GLAZIER FIRST FOLLOWED
BY SENATOR PAN SENATOR GLAZER
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS AND I
CERTAINLY JOIN WITH THE PRO TEM
AND MANY HERE ON THE FLOOR IN
THIS IMPORTANT RECOGNITION OF
OUR HOSPITALS. YOU KNOW WE
DON'T LIVE OUR LIFE PREPARING
FOR DISASTER BUT THOSE IN THE
HOSPITAL COMMUNITY DO JUST
THAT. BUT WHAT THEY DON'T
EXPECT. I AS THEY PREPARE TO
CARE FOR THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
INJURED IS THAT THE DISASTER
COMES THROUGH THEIR FRONT DOOR
WHERE THEY BECOME ON THE FRONT
LINES. OF THIS PANDEMIC THAT WE
EXPERIENCED AND SO I RISE TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION AND
THOSE OF MY CONSTITUENTS. FOR
OUR WONDERFUL HOSPITALS FOR THE
EXECUTIVES FOR THE DOCTORS AND
NURSES IN THE WONDERFUL STAFF
THAT HAVE STEPPED INTO THE
FRONT LINES- IN SUCH A AMAZING
INTO ROADWAYS. AND WE COULD
NEVER THANK THEM ENOUGH FOR ALL
THAT THEY DO FOR US BUT I
RESPECT THE ASTRONAUT. THANK
YOU SENATOR GLAZER CENTER PAN
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR RUBIO THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT SATURDAY TO-
RISE AND SUPPORT THIS YEAR FOR
ONE THINKS ARE PRO TEM FOR
RECOGNIZING HOSPITAL WE CAN
PROBABLY BE A CO AUTHOR. OF
HOSPITALS APART THE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR OUR SOCIETY
AND THEY'RE NOT JUST NEARLY
BUSINESSES THEY ARE THE CENTER
OF COMMUNITIES- THEY ARE THE
SITES WHICH CANNOT CLOSE- EVEN
AND OFTEN TIMES THE GREATEST
THE DISASTERS AND- WHETHER
IT'S- CODED OR- EARTHQUAKES ARE
ARE YOU ARE WILDFIRES. WE NEED
OUR HOSPITALS TO BE ABLE TO
STAY OPEN AS LONG AS POSSIBLE
AND TO HAVE OTHER HOSPITALS AND
SUPPORT- WHEN THESE THINGS
HAPPEN HOSPITALS ALSO ARE
CRITICAL PLACES FOR OUR HEROES
TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO DO
THEIR WORK TO TAKE CARE OF OUR
LOVED ONES. AND THE MOST OF ALL
OF OUR SOCIETY L. DOCTORS
NURSES. OTHER HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS HOSPITAL WORKERS
THERE STAFF THE PEOPLE WHO ACT
MAINTAIN AND KEEP CLEAN THESE
FACILITIES. THEY ARE HEROES WHO
CONTINUE TO GO. TO WORK EVEN IN
THE FACE OF DANGER IN PERSONAL
RISK. AND HOSP PROVIDE THE
PLACE FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT WORKS TO SAVE LIVES. SO AS
WE ARE CERTAINLY- FOR THIS
YEAR- WE ARE CELEBRATING
HOSPITAL EEK THEY TRIED TO
SERVE A HOSPITAL YEAR FOR
EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE DONE. BUT
WE CERTAINLY WANT TO THANK OUR
HOSPITALS AND ALL THE PEOPLE
WHO WORK WITH THEM IN THEM FOR
THEIR SACRIFICE AND DEDICATION
TO THE CARE OF CALIFORNIANS AS
WE FACE THIS TERRIBLE. PANDEMIC
AND OTHER DISASTERS. I WANT TO
THANK THE HOSPITAL COMMUNITY
FOR REALLY STEPPING UP IN A
TIME WHERE WE ALL NEED IT.
THEIR SUPPORT. GENERALLY WE'RE
ALL DEALING WITH OUR OWN
PERSONAL TRAUMAS AT HOME AND
THESE HEROES REALLY STEPPED UP
TO NOT ONLY CARRY. THEIR OWN
pPERSONAL LOAD. BUT OUR
EMOTIONAL LOAD AS WELL AND SO I
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE IN THE HOSPITAL
COMMUNITY THE DOCTORS THE
NURSES THE ADMINISTRATORS. YOU
KNOW IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING
THAT THEY REALLY SACRIFICED A
LOT OF THEIR OWN PERSONAL
LIVES. A NEW BOMB NURSES WHO
WERE STAYING IN HOSPITAL I'M
SORRY IN HOTELS. AND WEREN'T
ABLE TO SEE THEIR CHILDREN FOR
A COUPLE OF WEEKS AND SACRIFICE
OF US TO ENSURE THAT THEY WERE
HEALTHY. TO BE IN THE HOSPITALS
TO TAKE CARE OF ALL THE
PATIENTS THAT WERE COMING
THROUGH THEIR DOORS. SO I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE YOU YOU BECAME OUR
HERO STREAM THIS- PRESIDENT AT
TIME OF THIS PANDEMIC BUT
YOU'VE ALWAYS BEEN THERE EVEN
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC SO WITH
THAT I ALSO URGE WAS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO SENATOR MAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M
PROUD TO STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION. AND WANT TO THANK
THE PRO TEM FOR PUTTING
FORWARD. OUR HOSPITALS AND
HEALTHCARE WORKERS ARE THE
HEROES OF THIS PANDEMIC-
THEY'VE SAVED COUNTLESS LIVES
IN EACH AND EVERY ONE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. NOW MANY OF YOU
KNOW THAT I WAS HOSPITALIZED
MYSELF LOOK OF IN NINETEEN
SYMPTOMS BACK IN JANUARY. AND
WHILE YOU NEVER WANT TO STAY
OVERNIGHT IN A HOSPITAL- THOSE
NURSES HEALTH CARE WORKERS
DOCTORS NEED THAT EXPERIENCE AS
AS PLEASANT AND- COMFORTABLE.
AS POSSIBLE AND I FELT
CONFIDENT THAT I HAD WORLD
CLASS TREATMENT. I'M PROUD TO
HAVE SEVERAL WORLD CLASS
HOSPITALS IN MY DISTRICT
INCLUDING UC IRVINE HI SIR HOPE
MEMORIAL CARE AND MANY OTHERS.
THESE HOSPITALS ARE SOME OF THE
LARGEST EMPLOYERS IN MYDISTRICT POWERING OUR LOCAL
FORCE WORK FORCE AND MAKING
INVALUABLE CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
ECONOMY. I WANT TO ECHO THE
SENTIMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE
HEALTH CARE WORKERS AND
HOSPITALS. HAVE BEEN THE HEROES
OF THIS PANDEMIC THEY'VE LIFTED
OUR STATE AND NATION THROUGH
THE PANDEMIC- BECAUSE OF THEIR
DILIGENT AND SELFLESS WORK.
THEIR SACRIFICES WERE GETTING
CLOSER TO NORMALCY I ALSO WANT
TO GIVE US PARTICULAR SHOUT OUT
TO MY WOMAN OF THE YEAR FOR MY
DISTRICT JOY AND FEW MERA. WE
RECOGNIZED AS ONE OF THE YEAR-
SHE'S A KAISER HOSPITAL NURSE
HERSELF IN ITS FOR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO SO MANY LIKE
HER- THAT HAD IT REALLY POWERED
US THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC I
URGE- I VOTE. ON S. C. R. FORTY
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR MAN IS THERE ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS.
ITEM ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. THIS AL. WITH YOU LIKE
TO CALL. JUST ONE MOMENT.
PASSING ON THE CLOSE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA BY ATKINS FIVE BASE
HI BECKER FIVE FOUR JUST HI
BRADFORD I HAVE I GOTTA. HI
CORTESE HI DOLLY HI DODD. HI
TORONTO HI ADNAN. GLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG HI WESTELL HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I. LEIVA. FIVE WIRE HI
MELINDA'S FIVE MEN FIVE NEWMAN
I NELSON HI A SHOW OF BOTH. I
PAN HI FORTUNE TINO HI ROTH HI
RUBIO. HI SKINNER HI AMBER I
LIKE OUR SKI HI WINNER HI WILKE
HI THANK YOU SENATOR RECKONS
MOVES A CALL WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON INTO THIS FILE ORDER NOW
WITH FILING A NUMBER NINE
FOLLOWED BY A FINALITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN BOTH WITH SENATOR
ARCHULETA SAID ARCHULETA. ARE
YOU READY. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
SIR. HOLD ON ONE SECOND
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TWENTY
THREE BY SENATOR ARCHULETA
RELATIVE TO NATIONAL MILITARY
APPRECIATION MONTH. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AT C. R.
TWENTY THREE TO KERRY IN MAY AS
NATIONAL MILITARY APPRECIATION
MONTH. IN THE MONTH OF MAY
AMERICA GATHERS AROUND ITS
MILITARY FAMILY TO HONOR
REMEMBER RECOGNIZE AND
APPRECIATE THOSE WHO SERVE AND
HAVE SERVED AND REFLECT. ON OUR
SHARED HISTORY. NATIONAL
MILITARY APPRECIATION MONTH
INCLUDES LOYALTY DAY VICTORY IN
EUROPE DAY MILITARY SPOUSE
APPRECIATION DAY ARMED FORCES
DAY AND OF COURSE MEMORIAL DAY.
THESE ARE MORE THAN WE HAVE FOR
EVERYONE TO KNOW THAT IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THERE ARE MORE THAN
THIRTY MAJOR DEFENSE
INSTALLATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
INCORPORATING ALL MILITARY
SERVICES MORE THAN ANY OTHER
STATE IN THE UNION. EACH OF
THESE BASES HAS UNIQUE
IMPORTANT MILITARY VALUE AND
EACH IS MAKING CRITICAL
CONTRIBUTIONS TO NATIONAL
SECURITY TODAY AND IN THE
FUTURE. FOR OUR COUNTRY. THE
ACCOUNT FOR A HUNDRED AND
840-005-0040 NINE ACTIVE DUTY
NATIONAL GUARD AND RESERVE
PERSONNEL STATIONED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS VERY
IMPORTANT MONTH HONORS
REMEMBERS RECOGNIZES AND
APPRECIATES ALL MILITARY
PERSONNEL WHO HAVE SERVED
THROUGHOUT OUR HISTORY. ALL WHO
SERVE IN UNIFORM NOW AND OF
COURSE THEIR FAMILIES AS WELL
AS THE AMERICANS WHO HAVE GIVEN
THEIR LIVES IN DEFENSE OF OUR
FREEDOMS WE ALL ENJOY TODAY FOR
THESE REASONS I ASK YOU TO
PLEASE JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING
MAY AS A NATIONAL MILITARY
APPRECIATION MONTH AND I ASK
FOR YOUR- VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR ARCHER LET IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. ST ARCHULETA DO YOU
HAVE A CLOSING COMMENT THANK
YOU AND PLEASE REMEMBER ALL THE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO SERVED OUR
GREAT COUNTRY THANK YOU AN
ARCHER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY AND ALL
THE VETERANS HERE THIS MORNING.
THE SECRETARY PLEASE READ. I'M
SORRY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA BY ATKINS I
BASE I BECKER. HI FORGES HI
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T. HI
CORTESE HI DALLY HI TODD HI
DERISIVE HI EGGMAN. GLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH HI
HERZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER HI
LAYERED. HI LLEVA I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S HI MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON I A SHOW OF BOTH I PAN.
HI FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH HI
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER I AM BERG HI
WHAT KIND OF SKI. HI WINNER I
WELL I. THANK YOU SENATOR
ARCHULETA MOVES A CALL WE'RE
GONNA TAKE UP FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN WITH CENTER ARCHULETA
FOLLOWED BY FILING TWENTY THREE
CENTER ANGELA. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL THREE NINETY
TWO BY SENATOR ARCHULETA AN ACT
RELATING TO COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS SYNERGY LETTER
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY TWO REGARDING HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION ELECTRONIC.
DOCUMENT DELIVERY. THIS BILL
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY TWO
WILL IMPROVE ACCESSIBILITY TO
IMPORTANT DOCUMENTS AND REDUCE
DELIVERY COSTS BY REQUIRING
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION TO
COMMUNICATE WITH HOMEOWNERS VIA
EMAIL. UNLESS A RESIDENT
CHOOSES TO RECEIVE
COMMUNICATIONS VIA ANOTHER
METHOD SUCH AS TRADITIONAL MALE.
CALIFORNIA COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS ARE GOVERNED BY
THEIR RESPECTIVE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS WHICH ARE REQUIRED
TO FOLLOW THE REGULATIONS AND
GUIDELINES ESTABLISHED IN THEIR
INDIVIDUAL BYLAWS IN UNDER THE
STATE'S DAVID STERLING COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENT ACT. UNDER
THE DAVIS STERLING ACT
ASSOCIATIONS MUST PROVIDE
MEMBERS WITH NECESSARY
DOCUMENTS INCLUDING ANNUAL
BUDGETS POLICY STATEMENTS OR
NOTICES VIA FIRST CLASS MAIL
UNLESS ELECTRONIC DELIVERY IS
OTHERWISE REQUESTED BY THE
INDIVIDUAL. PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION HAS SOUGHT TO
IMPROVE UP TO PROTECT
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION MEMBERS
FROM EXORBITANT FEES BY
LIMITING THE AMOUNT
ASSOCIATIONS COULD CHARGE FOR
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
PROCESSING PREPARING AND
DELIVERING THESE DOCUMENTS.
ADDITIONALLY TO FURTHER
INCREASE INFORMATION
ACCESSIBILITY THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED SENATE BILL THREE TO
THREE AND TWENTY NINETEEN WHICH
REQUIRED A HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION TO THE OVER
MEMBERSHIP BOARD ELECTION RULES
BY INDIVIDUALS BY POSTING A
WEBSITE. IN THE MIDST OF GLOBAL
PANDEMIC WERE MAIL DELAYS ARE
COMMON COST SAVINGS ARE CRUCIAL
CRITICAL INFORMATION
ACCESSIBILITY IS VITAL. UPDATED
THESE PROCESSES TO BE
ELECTRONIC IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY TWO MANDATES HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION TO ELECTRONICALLY
DELIVER NOTICES AND DOCUMENTS
TO ITS MEMBERS BEGINNING
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY THREE IF
A RESIDENT OPTS IN TO RECEIVE
EMAIL COMMUNICATIONS OF A
RESIDENT WHO JUST NOT TO OPT
IN. THE ASSOCIATION WILL
CONTINUE TO DELIVER THE
DOCUMENTS BY MAIL HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS CAN ALSO CHOOSE TO
OPT OUT OF ELECTRONIC DELIVERY
IF TWO THIRDS OF THEIR MEMBERS
VOTE IN FAVOUR OF A DIFFERENT
FORM OF DOCUMENT AND NOTICED
DELIVERY. ALSO SENATE BILL
THREE NINETY TWO WAS AMENDED TO
CLARIFY THAT A RESIDENT'S
PERSONAL INFORMATION PROVIDED
TO HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION IS
PROTECTED AND RESIDENTS WILL BE
FULLY INFORMED. OF THE OPT IN
EMAIL COMMUNICATIONS PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU CENTER ARCH
ALETTA ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI YOUR RECOGNIZE.
MISTER PRESIDENT- I'M GOING TO
RESPECTFULLY SAY OFFER THIS
BILL TODAY I'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE SOME
FOLKS MAY REMEMBER. A COUPLE
YEARS AGO I DID S. P. THREE TWO
THREE WHICH ADDED EMAIL
ADDRESSES AS PART OF THE
ASSOCIATION RECORDS AND THIS IS
WHAT I'M WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR. THE CHALLENGE HERE IS
THAT THE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION. SHOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO USE THE EMAIL ADDRESS FOR
DOCUMENT DELIVERY AS WELL AS
HER OWN EMAIL COMMUNICATIONS
WHEN THEY IF THEY IF THE
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION IT IS
BLOCKING. ACCESS TO EMAIL
ADDRESSES FOR OTHER HOMEOWNERS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO USE OUR EMAIL
SECURITY K. WHAT MEMBERS OF THE
FELLOW WAS A HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION OBVIOUSLY IS AN
EXCEPTION OF THE OWNER REQUEST
THAT THE MAIL NOT BE SHARED. OF
COURSE BUT- TRYING TO GET THE
CLARIFICATION ON THAT BECAUSE
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE IN THIS
ROUND. REALLY CARE ABOUT THAT
SO BY. RESPECTFULLY WILL SET
OFF OF IT. THANK YOU SO I CAN
SEE THE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEN ARCHULETA WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECT THE
ASHER I VOTE THANK YOU SINATRA.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA HI AT KINS
BY FACE HI BECKER. HI FOR JUST
I BRADFORD. I HAVE I GOTTA. HI
CORTESE HI DOLLY FIVE DOT. I
TORONTO HI ADNAN. GLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES HI GROSS.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
HI JONES I CAN'T LONGER FIVE
LAYERED I LLEVA. I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S HI MEN FIVE NEWMAN I
NELSON BY A SHOW OF BOTH. I PAN
FIVE FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER HI NUMBER NINE
I LIKE HOW SKI. WINNER FIVE
WELK HI SYNERGEN REMOVES A CALL
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON THE
FINAL ITEM TWENTY THREE
FOLLOWED BY THIRTY NINE DOLLARS
AND TWENTY THREE ISN'T A
REQUIRE SERVICING REQUIRES
READY SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY ONE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AN ACT RELATING
TO TELECOMMUNICATIONS.
SERIGRAPH THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT INDIA MEMBERS
OUR PHONES OUR LIFELINES IS HOW
WE KEEP IN TOUCH WITH THE REST
OF THE WORLD THAT WILL RECEIVE
EMERGENCY ALERTS. YET UP UNTIL
LAST YEAR CURRENT-TELECOMMUNICATION SYSTEM ISN'T
MANDATED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
BACK UP POWER IS B. THREE FORTY
ONE PROVIDES THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION EXPLICIT
AUTHORITY TO CREATE BACKUP
POWER RULES FOR CELL TOWERS
LAND LINE OPERATIONS. IN CABLE
PHONE SYSTEMS THE BILL ALSO
MANDATES AT THE STATE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES SHARES
INFORMATION AT THE RTC FROM
TELECOM COMPANIES ON NETWORK
OUTAGES TO THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. WE'VE TAKEN AN
IMMENSE TO CLARIFY THE EXISTING
CPUC PROCEEDINGS WILL NOT BE
AFFECTED AND WE CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH ALL SIDES ON THIS
BILL WHICH I'M VERY GRATEFUL
FOR. ALL SIDES CONTINUE TO BE
ABLE TO ENGAGE THIS BILL
SUPPORTED BY THE FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION C. SHARES ARE C. R.
C.'S WELLESLEY CITIES
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE.
THANK YOU SIR REQUIRE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ON SP
THREE FORTY ONE DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE MR MCGUIRE
EXACTLY WITH RESPECT TO ASPEN I
DON'T HAVE A WONDERFUL WEEKEND
AND THANK YOU SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
HI ATKINS HI BABES. BACKER.
FIVE FORGES FIVE BRADFORD I
HAVE A AUTO HI CORTESE I DALLY.
HI TODD. FIVE THE RISE. HI
ADNAN. GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES
HIGH GROWTH. HI HURTS BERG HI
WITH SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES.
CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA.
HI WIRE HI MELINDA'S I MEN. I
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN BY A SHOW OF
BOTH I CAN. HI FORTUNE TINO. HI
ROSS HI RUBIO I SKINNER HI I'M
BERG HI FIVE WORKOUTS SKI. HI
WINNER I WILL HI. THANK YOU SIR
MCGUIRE MOVES THE CALL WE'RE
GOING NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY NINE FOLLOWED BY
FORTY. SENATOR HERTZBERG ARE
YOU READY FOR FILE I'M THIRTY
NINE YES SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOUR FORTY THREE BY%
SENATOR HERTZBERG AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT. THE
CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE
REFERENDUM THE RECALL IN THE
INITIATIVE PROCESS OF EMPOWERED
THE PEOPLE WITH A REFORM EFFORT
THAT STARTED OVER A HUNDRED
YEARS AGO THIS MEASURE DEALS
WITH REFERENDUMS. AND
REFERENDUMS ARE CONFUSING AND
DISADVANTAGEOUS THE WAY THE LAW
CURRENTLY WORKS. BASICALLY WHAT
HAPPENS IS A U. S. AS IN THE-
IN THE NOSE YES AND WE'VE SEEN
THAT TIME AND TIME AGAIN. WHEN
THERE'S A PROPONENT AND THE
ELECTORS LOOK AT THE ELECTORATE
LOOKS AT A MEASURE THEY THINK
THE PROPONENTS WANT YES THE WAY
THE CURRENT LAW WORKS ON A
REFERENDUM THE PROPONENTS WANT
A NO AND THE OPPONENTS WANNA
YES SECONDLY. THAT EVEN THOUGH
OFTEN THESE MEASURES ARE. ARE
PUT ON THE BALLOT A QUALIFIED
EARLY THEY'RE NOT PUT INTO THE
END OF THE BALLOT. SO THIS IS A
COMPANION TO S. A SU SENATE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT NUMBER
ONE AS A STATUTORY LANGUAGE TO
BOTH SAY ONE. THAT THE BALLOT
MEASURES THAT THESE REFERENDUMS
ARE TO BE PUT ON THE BALLOT IN
ORDER TO QUALIFY AND TO. TO
CLARIFY THAT THE PROPONENTS
WANT TO YES AND THE OPPONENTS
WANT TO KNOW SO VOTERS ARE
CONFUSED AS THEY HAVE BEEN IN
THE PAST ASPIRIN I VOTE. THANK
YOU SIR FOR ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. ON SB FOUR FORTY THREE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE CENTERS FOR WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. FIVE OH THANK
YOU THANK YOU SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS HI BATES
NO BACKER. I PORCHES. BRADFORD
HI CABRERA HI CORTESE HI DALLY
NO DODD HI TORONTO HI ADNAN.
GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES HIGH
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG HI WITH SO.
HI HER TADO HI JONES. NO CAN
LONGER I LAYERED I LLEVA HI
WIRE HI MELINDA'S NO MAN HI
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A CHOKE. HI
PAM. HI FORTUNE TINO. HI ROTH
HI RUBIO HI SKINNER HI AMBER
ALL RIGHT HI LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL. HI SERVERS
BURGERS ARE CALLED MEMBERS ARE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FORTY
FOLLOWED BY FORTY ONE ITEM
FORTY IS CENTER WILKES CENTER
WILL CARRY READY. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FIVE
OH NINE BY SENATOR WEALTH AND
ACTUALLY DID TO HEALING ARTS IN
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
THERE WILL BE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS BEFORE
YOU TODAY IS SP FIVE OH NINE
WHICH WHICH MAKES IT EASIER FOR
ATOMIC TREE STUDENTS TO BEGIN
WORKING AND PAYING OFF THEIR
STUDENT DEBTS DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THE PANDEMIC HAS
AFFECTED EVERY ASPECT OF OUR
LIVES DURING THE PAST YEAR AND
IT'S BEEN ESPECIALLY HARMFUL
IMPACT ON OUR STATE'S ATOMIC
TREE STUDENTS WERE FORCED TO
TRAVEL TO NORTH CAROLINA DURING
A GLOBAL PANDEMIC SIMPLY TO
BECOME LICENSED THIS BOOK
PROVIDES A NARROW AND TEMPORARY
SOLUTION TO ENABLE THE STUDENTS
TO OBTAIN TEMPORARY LICENSES
AND BEGIN WORKING UNDER THE
DIRECT SUPERVISION OF A FULLY
LICENSE ATOMIC TRYSTS DURING
THESE TRYING TIMES WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING FOR CREATIVE SOLUTIONS
TO HELP ALLEVIATE STUDENT LOAN
DEBT FOR OUR STUDENTS AND TO
REDUCE BARRIERS FOR MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS SEEKING TO ENTER
THE WORKFORCE. AND THIS BILL
DOES BOTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A NIGHT OUT THANK YOU SIR
WILL CAN YOU DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON SP. FIVE OH NINE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE SIX PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA BY ATKINS.
BATES FIVE BACKER. I PORCHES HI
BRADFORD FIVE BETO HI CORTEZ
THREE. I DALLY FIVE DOT HI
TORONTO HI ADNAN HI GLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH. HI
HERZBERG HI WITH SO HI HER TADO
FIVE JONES HI CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. HI LLEVA I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S FIVE MEN HI NEWMAN I
NELSON HI A TELEPHONE HI PAM.
HI FORTUNE TINO. I ROCK. I
RUBIO HI SKINNER HI AMBERG
RIGHT I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER.
I WOKE. HI PLEASE CALL THE
UPSET MEMBERS. ATKINS. ITEM
PASSES THIRTY SEVEN EYES THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO ITEM PASSES NEXT
REMOVING ON ITEM FORTY ONE
FOLLOWED BY I'M BY FORTY TWO
CENTER HERZBERG EUROPE ON FORTY
ONE CENTRES PREPARES TO BE
READY SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE TWENTY NINE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTRICITY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT AS
FOR THE LAST TWENTY YEARS WE
HAVE BEEN GRAPPLING WITH THE
CONVERSION FROM THE OLD SYSTEM
OF POWER PROVIDING TO A NEW
MODERNIZED RENEWABLE SYSTEM IN
THAT REGARD WE HAVE BEEN
DEALING. IN INTENSE WAY WITH
UNDERSTANDING RESOURCE ADEQUACY
PLANNING AND MAKING SURE THAT
ALL OF THE VARIOUS PROVIDERS
HAVE NECESSARY RESOURCES WE
DON'T SUFFER BLACKOUTS AND
BROWNOUTS THAT WE DID. MORE
THAN TWENTY YEARS AGO THIS
MEASURE CLARIFIES THAT IT THE
EXISTING P. UC ADOPTS A CENTRAL
RESOURCE ADEQUACY STANDARD
BUYERS WILL FAIRLY. ASSESS
THOSE COSTS AMONG MULTIPLE
YEARS BUT SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE
CLARIFIED IN THE LOSS FOR AND I
BOTH. MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THOMAS
I'M SORRY THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ITEM
PASSES. THIRTY SEVEN TO ZERO.
THANK YOU MOVING ON. FILE AND
I'M FORTY TWO SENATOR I CAL SKI
WILL BE FOLLOWED BY A FILE ITEM
FORTY THREE CENTER ACCOUNTS
GIVE PEERS TO BE READY
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL- PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY
ONE BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKIS
AN ACT RELATING TO CONSUMER
DEBT. SO I GUESS HE WAS
PRESENT. IN THE PAST WE'VE
PASSED. LEGISLATION WHEN DEBT
COLLECTORS BY DEBT TO GIVE
CONSUMERS THE RIGHT TO REQUEST.
PROOF THAT THEY OWE THE DEBT
ALONG WITH SOME OTHER BASIC
INFORMATION. WE'VE SEEN IS A
LOT OF DEBT COLLECTORS NOT
BUYING THAT THEY'RE GETTING
DATA SCIENCE TO THIS BILL SP
FIVE THREE WOULD REQUIRE DEBT
COLLECTORS WHO HAVE DELINQUENT
DEBTS ASSIGNED TO THEM. TO HAVE
TO SHOW PROOF THAT THEY HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO COLLECT ON THE
DEBT ADDITIONALLY THE BILL ADDS
A SIMPLE GOODBYE LETTER FOR
ANOTHER WORDS HAVING YOUR DESK
PHONE OR THE RITUAL THEN OR
NOTIFY THE CONSUMER- TO WHOM
THEY'RE SELLING OR ASSIGNING TO
GET ALONG WITH THE REMAINING
BALANCE. AND WITH THAT THIS IS
A BILL ABOUT TRANSPARENCY ABOUT
RECORD KEEPING AND PROTECTIONS
FOR CONSUMERS. AND I WOULD HIRE
HER CAN I VOTE. THANK YOU SIR
RIGHT. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI AT
KINS. BATES NO BACKER. HI
PORGES NO BRADFORD I HAVE A I
DON'T. HI CORTESE HI DALLY NO
DODD FIVE TORONTO HI ADNAN. HI
GLAZER. GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG. HI WAY SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES NO CAN LONGER. HI
LAYERED HI LLEVA FIVE MCGUIRE
HI MELINDA'S. NO MAN HI NEWMAN
I NELSON NO A CHOKE NO PAN. HI
FORTUNE TINO HI ROTH HI RUBIO I
SKINNER I AM BERG I LIKE CASKEY
HI WINNER FIVE WILKE NOW. THE
TICKET WAS CALLED ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS GLAZER I THIS
THANK YOU THE- THE TWENTY EIGHT
I VOTES NINE NO VOTES THE ITEM
PASSES. AND MOVING ON TO ITEM
FORTY THREE. SENATOR DODD
HERE'S TO BE READY SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL FIVE
FIFTY SIX BY SENATOR DODD AND
ACTUALLY DID COMMUNICATIONS
CENTER THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SP FIVE FIVE SIX WOULD
BRING CALIFORNIA INTO
CONFORMANCE ITH EXISTING
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW SEEKING
TO ACCELERATE THE DEPLOYMENT OF
WIRELESS BROADBAND NETWORK
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. DEMAND FOR RELIABLE
HIGH SPEED BROADBAND
CONNECTIVITY HAS NEVER BEEN
HIGHER THAN IT IS TODAY. THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS
ONLY ELEVATED THE EXTENT TO
WHICH BROADBAND ACCESS ACCESS
SKEWS ME HAS BECOME ESSENTIAL
FOR PARTICIPATING VIRTUALLY IN
EVERY ASPECT OF MODERN SOCIETY.
YET TO MANY HOUSEHOLDS ACROSS
THE STATE CAN'T EVEN ACCESS
BROADBAND BECAUSE IT'S NOT
AVAILABLE OR THE SIGNAL WHERE
THEY LIVE IS SO WEAK. AS
LEARNING HAS SHIFTED ONLINE
STUDENTS STRUGGLED TO KEEP MAY
STRUGGLE TO KEEP UP ADULTS AND
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT INTERNET
ACCESS MAY NOT ABLE TO BE ABLE
TO SEARCH OR APPLY FOR JOBS.
WORK REMOTELY START BUSINESSES
OR ACCESS EDUCATIONAL SOCIAL
AND OTHER RESOURCES NEEDED TO
THRIVE IN THE DIGITAL ECONOMY.
THAT'S THREE FIVE FIVE SIX WILL
ADDRESS THOSE NEEDS BY
CONFORMING CALIFORNIA LAW WITH
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FCC
FEDERAL REGULATION IN ORDER TO
EXPAND F. G. FIVE G. EXCUSE ME
FIVE G. DEPLOYMENT AND
CONTRIBUTE TO CLOSING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE. THIS BILL
REQUIRES LOCALITIES TO GIVE
ACCESS TO THEIR STREET LIGHTS
AND TRAFFIC SIGNAL POLES IN
ORDER FOR TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANIES TO ATTACH THEIR
WIRELESS FACILITIES. THE BILL
FOCUSES ON ENSURING THAT ACCESS
TO THESE POLLS IS PROVIDED AT A
NON DISCRIMINATORY COST BASED
RATES. IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THE FCC ISSUED AN
INFRASTRUCTURE ORDER THAT
REQUIRES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PROVIDE A COST BASED RATE FOR
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES TO
ATTACH THESE FACILITIES.
HOWEVER MANY LOCALITIES ARE
INTERPRETING THE INTERPRETING
THE FEDERAL ORDER
INCONSISTENTLY. THERE'S BEEN
WIDESPREAD RESISTANCE NON
COMPLIANCE IN CONTINUING
LITIGATION OVER THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ORDER. GOOD
FAITH NEGOTIATIONS HAVE BEEN
TAKING PLACE AMONG STAKEHOLDERS
IN MY TEAM. WELL I'VE TAKEN A
MA'AM IT'S ADDRESSING THE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS RAISED BY
STAKEHOLDERS SUCH AS THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES SUCH AS ATHLETICS
AESTHETIC STANDARDS AND SAFETY
AND TIMING I KNOW THERE'S MORE
TO WORK ON SPECIFICALLY IN THE
AREA OF EQUITY ISSUES. IN A
DEAL FOR ME WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE LEAGUE- AND SEEING THEIR
OPPOSITION AT THE VERY
BEGINNING ON THIS BILL WHICH
WAS SO. EXPANSIVE IN TODAY I
TALKED TO HIM YESTERDAY THE BIG
ISSUES WERE EQUITY MAKING SURE
THE COMMUNITIES REGARDLESS OF
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THEY HAVE
HAVE THE SAME ACCESS TO THIS.
BROADBAND AS ANYBODY ELSE IN
WEALTHIER COMMUNITIES AND I
PLEDGE TO WORK MY TAIL OFF AS
THIS THING GOES FORWARD TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT GETS THAT THOSE
ISSUES GET TAKEN CARE OF IN IN
IN THIS BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I VOTE ON THIS
CRITICALLY. NEEDED LEGISLATION
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD- MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE WILL
RECOGNIZE. SENATOR HERTZBERG
FIRST. THINGS PRESIDENT JUST
VERY BRIEFLY. WE'RE GOING TO
REVOLUTION AND THIS PANDEMIC
HAS EXACERBATED AN
EXTRAORDINARY WAY TO EXPRESS
ITS IMPORTANCE WHETHER IT'S
ACCESS FOR KIDS WHO STUDY IN.
SCHOOLS AND THAT'S THE BACKBONE
THE INTERNET THE BROADBAND FOR
G. AND THIRTY OF THE STATE HAVE
OUR HAD THE SUCH A WE HAVE GOT
TO MOVE QUICKLY I AM SEEN THIS
IN MIKE'S TRY A THE WORLD WERE
CUT HAVE A DA IN THE END IT ON
SPEED IN THE LIKE MY BROTHERS
RETIRED FROM THE CARRIES OVER
IN THAILAND HE TELLS ME HIS.
BROADBAND IS FASTER THAN IT WAS
HERE WHEN HE WAS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA JUST SOME WEEKS AGO
SO I JUST TELL YOU THAT I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS I'VE
STOOD UP IN COMMITTEE BEFORE
AND WILL STAND UP AGAIN WE NEED
TO MODERNIZE OUR SYSTEM THE
IMPACT THE ECONOMY IS
EXTRAORDINARY IT IS TIME TO
MOVE FORWARD AS FAST RELIABLE
THANK YOU CENTERS PERSON- PAN
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR WIENER
CENTER PANEL. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT CENTER SITE TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SP FIVE FIVE SIX
ONE THANK MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
NAPA FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
SMALL CELL CAN DEPLOYMENT HAS
BEEN A PRIORITY IN MY DISTRICT
AND I'M PROUD THE PROGRESS THAT
WE'VE MADE AND YET THIS
PANDEMIC HAS HIGHLIGHTED
HIGHLIGHTED JUST HOW MUCH WE
NEED THIS BILL SO THAT WE CAN
GET RELIABLE HIGH SPEED
BROADBAND BROADBAND
CONNECTIVITY. IT WAS A
PHYSICIAN AND A PARENT I SEE
HOW. MUCH WE'RE DEPENDING ON
THIS NETWORK TO ENSURE THAT WE
CAN TAKE CARE OF PATIENTS AND
WE NEED CONNECTIVE ANY UPDATE
ON BOTH ENDS CONNECTIVITY DOES
NOT IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT ON THE
DOCTOR AND IT'S ON THE PATIENT
AND- WE HAVE NEIGHBORHOODS
DON'T HAVE CONNECTIVITY- THOSE
PATIENTS CANNOT GET. FAIR AND
THEN THINK ABOUT ALL THE KIDS
WHO ARE DEPENDENT ON DISTANCE
LEARNING- AND AS AN OPTION AS
WELL. AND THEN OF COURSE-
DURING COVE AND WE'VE SEEN HOW.
AT LEAST FOR SOME JOBS- HOW WE
CAN TRY TO ALSO DO MORE
DISTANCE WORK AS WELL REMOTE
WORKING. AND CERTAINLY FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY AS WELL. SO IT'S
SO VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE BUILD
OUT. THIS NETWORK THAT WE HAVE
IN THIS DISCUSSION WE ACTUALLY
HAVE TO REMEMBER HOW CRITICAL
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE IS TO-
PROVIDING. HEALTHCARE LEARNING
AND WORK. AND SO- BELLS. I
THINK THAT. IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT THIS INFRASTRUCTURE BE
BUILT OUT THAT WE HAVE
CONSISTENT. RULES FOR THAT-
AND- CERTAINLY- WANNA THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR CARING THIS BILL
BECAUSE WE CAN'T WE CAN'T JUST
KEEP TALKING ABOUT THIS- WE
NEED TO MAKE AN ACTIVITY A
REALITY. AND THIS BILL SIMPLY
CODIFIES FCC REGULATIONS TO BE
SO WE CAN BE MORE AGGRESSIVE
ABOUT FILLING IN THE DIGITAL
DESERT'S AND MAKING SURE THAT
FAMILIES HAVE ACCESS. TO THIS.
ESPECIALLY BASIC NEEDS THAT WE
NOW HAVE IN OUR MODERN SOCIETY
I- TONIGHT THANK. YOU THANK YOU
SIR PAN SENATOR WIENER. OKAY
YOU MR ROSE I RISE IN SUPPORT.
OF SB FIVE FIVE- SIX. ONE THANK
YOU- THE AUTHOR FOR BEING
WILLING TO WORK- WITH
STAKEHOLDERS- I THINK AS YOU'VE
HEARD FROM COLLEAGUES ON THE
NEED FOR FASTER ACCESS BECOMES
MORE MORE. NOT JUST IMPORTANT
BUT ESSENTIAL TO BE ABLE TO
FUNCTION IN MODERN DAY LIFE-
AND THE PANDEMIC ONLY.
MAGNIFIED THAT NEED BUT EVEN
AFTER THE KIND OF AMERICA THAT
NEED IS STILL. WITH US. AND THE
REALITY IS THAT IT IS FRANKLY
EMBARRASSING IN THIS COUNTRY IN
THE STATE- HELLO. HELLO THE
POOR INTERNET ACCESS THAT SO
MANY PEOPLE. HAVE WHEN YOU
COMPARE INTERNET SPEEDS IN THIS
COUNTRY TO OTHER COUNTRIES.
IT'S EMBARRASSING- AND THAT
THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE IN OUR
CITIES AND RURAL CALIFORNIA-
AND OTHER AREAS THAT LACK GOOD
ACCESS AND SO WE NEED. THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE- AND
UNFORTUNATELY I COME FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- AND I SPENT YOU
KNOW A LOT OF MANY MANY HOURS.
LISTENING TO APPEALS OF THIS OF
THE SIGHTING OF CELL. TOWERS I
KNOW OTHERS IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT
WHO WERE IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN
THIS BODY. HAD THE SAME
EXPERIENCE- AND UNFORTUNATELY
JUST GOT SO TIED UP- IN IN A
NEIGHBORHOOD POLITICS THAT WE
NEED A STREAMLINED. APPROACH
AND I THINK THAT THIS HELPS- TO
PROVIDE THAT- AS WITH- THE
SENATOR FROM SAN DIEGO'S BILL A%
FEW YEARS AGO WHICH IS A
BROADER VERSION OF THE SPELL
FRANKLY- THIS BILL CONTINUES IN
THIS WAS IMPORTANT TO ME. BACK
A FEW YEARS AGO AND IS
IMPORTANT NOW CONTINUES TO
PROVIDE CITIES. WITH
FLEXIBILITY IN TERMS OF DESIGN
STANDARDS- AND IN TERMS OF THIS
PRECISE CITING. SO THAT IF THE
CITY BELIEVES IT SHOULD BE A
QUICK NOD IN THIS AREA BUT
ACROSS THE STREET OR THIRTY
FEET AWAY THIS IS TOO CLOSE TO
SOMEONE'S HOUSE. BUT SARAH. THE
CITY. STILL HAS THE FLEXIBILITY.
I FOR THAT'S- CITING PLUS THE
DESIGN STANDARDS SO I THINK
IT'S A BILL WORTHY OF SUPPORT.
I DO WANT TO SAY THIS IS ONE
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE IN TERMS
OF. ENHANCING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH WE ARE
BEHIND ON AND WE NEED TO CATCH
UP- BUT IT'S NOT THE WHOLE
SOLUTION WE SAID WE NEED MORE
COMPETITION. BYE IN TERMS OF
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE
STILL TOO MANY PARTS OF THE
STATE. WHERE THAT PEOPLE
AFFECTED WE HAVE ONLY ONE
OPTION OR MAYBE TWO- AND THERE
ARE SMALLER START UPS THAT WANT
TO PROVIDE INTERNET ACCESS THAT
FRANKLY. PROVIDE BETTER AND
FASTER INTERNET ACCESS BUT THEY
ARE BLOCKED FROM EVEN ENTERING
THE MARKET SO WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT AS WELL BUT THIS IS A
GOOD STEP AND I SUPPORT IT.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER CENTER
DRAWS A. THANK YOU MR CHAIR-
I'M REALLY GLAD THAT THE
AUTHOR- TOOK UP THE ISSUE OF-
EQUITY IN OUR COMMUNITIES I
AGREE WITH STREAMLINING I AGREE
WITH MOVING FORWARD I AGREE
WITH MODERNIZING THOSE ARE ALL
GREAT CONCEPTS BECAUSE IN A LOT
OF OUR COMMUNITIES THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT IT IS IT'S A
CONCEPT THEY HAVE NO
CONNECTIVITY. IN LOS ANGELES IS
ONE EXAMPLE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS HAD NO
CONNECTIVITY. NOT EVEN NUMBER
OF PRODUCTIVITY THAT YOU SHOULD
MODERNIZE WE SHOULD GET A YOU
KNOW A SPEED HIGHER SPEED THAT
HAD NO CONNECTIVITY. SO HOW DO
WE REALLY LIVE UP TO THE THESE
TERMS THAT WERE USING THE
MODERNIZING AND MOVING FORWARD
WELL WE ARE EXCLUDING. WE ARE
EXCLUDING ENTIRE COMMUNITIES
FROM HAVING THE BASIC
CONNECTIVITY ARE YOU KNOW THE
TERMS ARE USED OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN AND IT GETS TO
THE POINT WHERE IT DOESN'T MEAN
ANYTHING IT DOESN'T MEAN-ANYTHING TO A LOT OF PEOPLE A
LOT OF CALIFORNIANS. AND THAT
YOU KNOW I REALLY GO TO TOWN ON
THE AUTHOR- TO LIVE UP TO THIS
COMMITMENT- BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS THERE IS A STATEWIDE-
OF THE SYSTEM OR WE WANT TO.
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S LEVEL
STATEWIDE AND THAT'S WHY WE
WANT TO STREAMLINE BUT IN SOME
WAYS WE ARE TAKING AWAY THE
ABILITY OF LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO
BE ABLE TO. PRESS FURTHER TO
MAKE SURE THEIR COMMUNITIES ARE
INCLUDED SO AGAIN I'M COUNTING
ON THE AUTHOR TO MOVE THIS AND
WHEN HE SAYS MOVE FORWARD THAT
THAT MEANS EVERYBODY ALL
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR DRAWS A SENATOR
RUBIO FOLLOWED BY SENATOR GROVE
SENATOR RUBIO. I THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I ALSO AND I THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FORWARD. I YOU KNOW I
MEAN TO- ONE ONLINE MY COMMENTS
WITH ALL OF THE COMMENTS
ALREADY STATED BUT IN
PARTICULAR YOU KNOW THE FACT
THAT WE NEED RELIABLE HIGH
SPEED BROADBAND CONNECTIVITY IS
NOW A MUST IS NO LONGER A
LUXURY- I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE HOW THE COMMENTS BY
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
THAT. THE EQUITY PIECE IS STILL
SOMEWHAT MISSING BUT I'M VERY
ENCOURAGED BY THE AUTHOR'S
COMMENTS THAT HE CONTINUES TO
WORK TO ENSURE THAT ALL VOICES
ARE HEARD AND HE CONTINUES TO
MAKE THIS MEASURE EVEN BETTER.
SO I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT I DO
BELIEVE THAT HE'LL GET THERE
ARE BUT I DO WANT TO JUST SHARE
THAT YOU KNOW I ALSO COME FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND I WOULD
HAVE BEEN THE FIRST ONE POSING
THIS MEASURE ON THE BASIS THAT
I DO BELIEVE IN LOCAL CONTROL.
NONE THE LESS- AS THE DOCTOR
STATED WE- YOU KNOW THIS IS AN
EVOLUTION AND IT'S ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY THAT WE MOVE FORWARD
CONSIDERING THAT YOU KNOW
THIRTY ONE OTHER STATES ARE
ALREADY THERE. IT'S TIME THAT
WE ALSO CATCH UP AND DIE IN
GENERAL WE'VE LEARNED NOT TO
THIS PANDEMIC IT'S BECOME A
NECESSITY IN OUR JOBS IN OUR
HOMES AND EDUCATION AND THE
DISPARITY STILL THERE AND SO WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS THERE. THE
EQUITY PIECES. THERE AND THAT
WE ALSO CAN YOU TOO AND THAT
LOW CAN. IS THERE AND SO I DO
KNOW THAT THIS HOUSE
FLEXIBILITY IN TERMS OF. DESIGN
STANDARDS FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
IT ALSO HAS- FLEXIBILITY IN
TERMS OF LOCATION AND I KNOW
THAT IT WILL BECOME A BETTER
MEASURE AS IT WAS FOR SO I ALSO
STAND IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO SENATOR
GROVE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
TOO- RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
FIVE SIX EIGHT WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PROVIDE REASONABLE. NON
DISCRIMINATORY ACCESS TO
LOCALLY- OWN STREET LIGHTS
POLES AND TRAFFIC SIGNAL POLES.
WHAT I MEAN BY NON
DISCRIMINATORY AS ITS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ALREADY ALLOW
UTILITIES TO BE ON THESE POLLS
SO MINE AT THE COMMUNICATIONS
INDUSTRY SO THAT WE CAN EXTEND
BROADBAND. TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
THAT REALLY- KIND OF FELL
THROUGH THE CRACKS DURING
COVERT WHEN WE DIDN'T HAVE THAT
SERVICE AVAILABLE. AT THE
EQUIPMENT IS ALREADY BEING USED
FOR UTILITIES LIKE I SAID
THERE'S ALSO A SAFE HARBOR IN
THE BILL WHERE THE- LOCAL.
GOVERNMENT CAN CHARGE MORE BUT
THERE'S A SAFE HARBOR OF TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY DOLLARS PER-
PULL FOR THEM TO MOUNT THAT
EQUIPMENT. IN THE PAST YEAR
WE'VE SEEN A GREAT NEED. FOR
ACCESS TO BROADBAND I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING. WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES IN THE CITIES AND
TAKING AMENDMENTS THAT BRINGS
ALMOST EVERY CITY OFF OF THIS
BILL AND I THANK HIM FOR TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS THAT
SPECIFICALLY MAKES MY CITIES-
FEEL VERY COMFORTABLE. IN THEIR
LOCAL CONTROL OPTIONS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I BOTH.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROVE CENTER
WAY SO. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND I YOU KNOW I JUST WANT TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF EQUITY ON
THIS- MEASURE BECAUSE IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I KNOW. A LOT OF
US WANT TO SEE EVERYONE IN OUR
COMMUNITY EVERYONE IN THE STATE
WE COVERED AND YOU HAVE ACCESS
TO TELECOMMUNICATIONS INTERNET
SERVICE. AND IT AND IT'S BEEN A
CHALLENGE AND I WANT TO SPEAK
TO A LITTLE BIT WHY AND WHY
THIS BILL. WOULD MAKE THE
PROCESS BETTER. AND BECAUSE
I'VE I'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
THROUGH OUR TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SIDE OF MY COMMITTEE FOR MANY
YEARS AND WE'VE BEEN PUSHING.
FUNDS THAT HELP. CREATE ACCESS
TO BUT BY BRINGING BRINGING
MORE ANTENNAS TO COMMUNITIES
ARE NORMALLY. UNDER SERVED SO
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WHEN YOU
HAVE A VERY SMALL COMMUNITY
THAT'S VERY LOW INCOME.
TELECOMMUNICATIONS IN OUR
COUNTRY ARE PRIVATE WE DON'T
REALLY HAVE PUBLIC RUN
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ALL THE
POLLS INFRASTRUCTURE. IS OWNED
PRIVATELY. AND THEY HAVE
DECIDED WHERE THEY WANT TO
PROVIDE SERVICE- JUST BY THE-
REGULAR MARKET DEMAND PROCESS.
AND OVER THE YEARS IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE COME IN TO
TRY TO GET THEM TO GO INTO
AREAS WHERE THEY DON'T WANT TO
GO BECAUSE THERE'S NO MONEY TO
BE MADE IN FACT THEY MIGHT EVEN
LOSE MONEY. THEY GO INTO THOSE
AREAS SO WE HAVE. CREATED A
SYSTEM WHERE WE SUBSIDIZE THE
PLACEMENT OF ANTENNAS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THOSE AREAS
SO THOSE COMMUNITIES CAN GET
ACCESS. EVEN IF THEY'RE NOT
PAYING THE FULL COST OF THE
SERVICES ARE BEING PROVIDED.
UNDER UNDER THIS BILL AND UNDER
PREVIOUS ACTIONS WE'VE TRIED TO
FIND WAYS TO. DEMOCRATIZE OR
THE DELIVERY OF SERVICE BUT
ALSO MAKE IT AFFORDABLE FOR
PEOPLE LIVING IN UNDERSERVED
AREAS AND TRY TO ENCOURAGE
THESE COMPANIES TO GO OUT TO
THOSE AREAS HAS BEEN VERY HARD.
OFTEN TIMES WE HAVE HEARD
STORIES ABOUT PEOPLE IN CERTAIN
AREAS NOT HAVING ACCESS. AND
AND WE HAVE FOUND THAT THEY DO
HAVE ACCESS BUT THEY JUST
THEY'RE JUST NOT CONNECTED AND
WE HAVE PROGRAMS TO CONNECT
THOSE PEOPLE IF THEY KNEW THESE
PROGRAMS EXISTED. SO THERE'S A
COMBINATION OF THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING WITH THIS BILL. WE
WILL TRY TO REGULATE WITH THIS
BUT WE'LL TRY TO REGULAR PRICE-
THE WAY WE DELIVER SERVICE
AROUND THE STATE. AND I CAN
GIVE SOME EXAMPLES FOR EXAMPLE
IN SOME MARKETS THAT HAVE A LOT
OF SUBSCRIPTION. THEY'RE
CHARGING UP TO FIFTEEN THOUSAND
PER ANTENNA PER MONTH. AND SOME
HAVE LAUNCHED A SUBSCRIPTION
THEY'RE CHARGING. SOMETIMES
SEVENTY TO A HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER ANTENNA AND THIS IS WHAT
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS GET. THIS
IS WHAT ALL REPAIRS AND A PAIN
SO IF YOUR REPAIR IN FRESNO OR
IMPERIAL COUNTIES OR IN VERY
UNDERSERVED AREAS. YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE BEING CHARGED BUT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE BEING
PAID. IN THE IN THE AREAS LIKE
LA AND SAN FRANCISCO COUNTY.
WHERE TEY'RE GETTING MORE
MONEY PER UN TENA. AND OFTEN
TIMES THAT IS NOT FAIR AND IT
ADDS COST TO THESYSTEM AND ARE
COMPLETELY UNNECESSARY AND
THOSE FUNDS ARE COLLECTED BY
CITIES DO NOT GO TOWARD MAKING.
THIS UP MORE ACCESSIBLE TO
UNDERSERVED AREAS YET THE STATE
DOES HAVE PROGRAMS. AND WE HAVE
A PROGRAM SET. BY BY VIRTUE OF
A STATE LAW. THAT MAKE THESE
THESE- FACILITIES MORE
ACCESSIBLE TO UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES SO THE STATE IS
REALLY DOING THE BRUNT OF THE
WORK OF MAKING SURE LOW LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES. ARE ARE
GETTING ACCESS THE LOCALS ARE
NOT AT ALL YET THE LOCALS ARE
GETTING PAID FOR THE ANTENNAS
THE STATE IS NOT. N. AND SO
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I THINK
WE NEED TO CORRECT IF WE ARE
REALLY CHAMPIONING THE CAUSE.
OF THE UNDERSERVED AND WE WANT
TO CREATE AN EQUITABLE SYSTEM
AND WE DO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
GET ACCESS WE HAVE TO FIND A
WAY. TO REGULARIZE THE DELIVERY
OF SERVICE TO MAKE SURE THAT
SOME AFFLUENT COMMUNITIES ARE
GETTING PAID MORE THAN THAN
THAN THAN. POORER COMMUNITIES-
THE AND IT KIND OF ADDS TO THE
INEQUITY OF HOW WE HAVE VERY
SOME VERY AFFLUENT POCKETS IN
OUR IN OUR STATE AND SOME THAT
ARE VERY POOR IT CONTINUES TO
ADD TO THAT EQUITY WE NEED TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM AND I WANT
TO CONGRATULATE THE AUTHOR OF
TAKING THIS BILL LAN. AND THE
ALL THE ALL THE VARIOUS WORK
THAT HAS COME OVER THE YEARS TO
DO THIS BUT I ALSO WANT TO
CURSE ALL OF YOU MEMBERS PLEASE
WHEN YOU'RE OUT THERE IN YOUR
DISTRICTS AND PEOPLE NEED
PHONES AND THEY NEED INTERNET
WE HAVE INTERNET SERVICE TO
THAT INCIDENT IN ALL
COMMUNITIES OF STATE ESPECIALLY
LOW IN COMMUNITIES. WHERE
FAMILIES CAN BE IT'S TEN
DOLLARS A MONTH FOR INTERNET
SERVICE THEIR SPECIAL PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE THE REAL EVEN GIVE
FAMILIES A FREE PHONE FREE
PHONE SERVICE LOW THE INTERNET
SERVICE SOME SOME CASES IT'S
POSSIBLE TO SET P A FREE
SERVICE IN CERTAIN POCKETS. AND
I JUST WANT TO ENCOURAGE
EVERYBODY AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
AND MOVE FORWARD TO IMPROVING
THE DELIVERY SERVICE ALSO GET
INFORMED OF ALL THE WONDERFUL
PROGRAMS WE HAVE IN OUR STATE.
TO HELP LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE- IF WE PARTICIPATE IN
THIS PROCESS. MORE PEOPLE GET
ACCESS WE'VE HAD. WE'VE HAD
CLINIC WE'VE HAD THESE FARES IN
OUR COMMUNITIES WHERE WE GO OUT
THERE. AND INFORM PEOPLE D.
THAT YOU QUALIFY FOR PHONE
SERVICE AND INTERNET SERVICE
AND PEOPLE ARE SHOCKED. THEY
NEVER HAD A PHONE OR SERVICE
AND ARE SHOCKED TO FIND THAT
THEY QUALIFY FOR ONE. AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
AVAILABLE. BUT UNSUBSCRIBED AND
WE HAVE PLENTY OF FUNDS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN HELP FAMILIES
AND ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY TO.
WORK ON THAT AS- THE AS YOU DO
ALL THE WONDERFUL WORK THAT YOU
DO YOUR DISTRICTS TO INCLUDE
THAT AS PART OF IT. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT FOR LET ME GO ON
AND FOR THE AUTHOR FOR THE WORK
THE STUFF ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON SB FIVE FIFTY SIX.
THE CENTER COPYRIGHT. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT- FOR THE
OPPORTUNITIES A FEW WORDS AND I
HAVE A STATEMENT AND THEN AT A
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR FIRST I
WANT TO SAY I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM NOT BUT
THE WORK THAT HE'S DONE AND THE
AMENDMENT SAID HE'S TAKEN I
THINK IS BILL HAS MOVED IN IN.
A DIRECTION THAT IS THAT'S
REALLY POSITIVE AND I WANT TO
SAY FROM THE FROM THE GET GO
THAT I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY BUT YOU KNOW PART OF
THE CHALLENGE THAT WE FACE IS
THAT THE FCC IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BASICALLY HAVE
PREEMPTED LOCAL THE STATE FROM
REGULATING BROADBAND INTERNET
SERVICES AND THOUGH THEY GIVE
US THE PARAMETERS AROUND HOW WE
CAN. HOW WE CAN INTERACT WITH
THE COMPANIES AND THEIR THEIR
THEORY IS THAT THIS IS AN
ENTERTAINMENT- FORUM AND WHAT
WE KNOW IS THAT THIS IS NO
LONGER ENTERTAINMENT THIS IS A
NECESSITY IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO FUNCTION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S A NECESSITY FOR
OUR CHILDREN TO BE ABLE TO GET
AN EDUCATION IT'S A NECESSITY
FOR US BECAUSE WE WERE SNT
HOME AND WE HAD TO- ZOOM OUR
MEETINGS FROM HOME AND IT'S A
NECESSITY FOR A BUSINESS
COMMUNITY BECAUSE FRANKLY MANY
OF THEM WOULD NOT HAVE
SURVIVED. BUT FOR INTERNET
OPPORTUNITIES AND SO- IF THIS
BILL WITHOUT QUESTION IS GOING
TO TAKE AWAY THE AUTHORITY OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO MAKE SOME
DECISIONS AND AS A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT REPRESENTATIVE FOR
MORE THAN FIFTEEN YEARS- I'M
NERVOUS AND I AND IT WORRIES ME
TO BE TAKING AWAY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CONTROL BECAUSE THE
LAST TIME WE DID IT WE ENDED UP
I THINK WITH PORTER CABLE
SERVICE- AND SO IF WE'RE GOING
TO DO THAT DO THAT I THINK WE
OUGHT TO GET SOMETHING IN
RETURN. AND SO WHAT I THINK WE
HAVE TO GET IN RETURN IS AN
INSURANCE AND ASSURANCE THAT
THERE WILL BE BROADBAND ACCESS
TO DISADVANTAGED AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
SAN DIEGO ON IN MY COMMUNITY
THIS IS NOT A QUESTION OF
PAYING- A GETTING A DISCOUNT ON
YOUR INTERNET IT'S NOT A
QUESTION OF BEING ABLE TO- TO
GET THIS SIR. BUT IT'S NOT.
WHAT WANT THERE IS JUST NO
SERVICE PERIOD. AND SO IF WE'RE
GOING TO. PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO PUT THESE
SMALL CELLS AND TO BE ABLE TO
TELL LOCAL GOVERNMENT OKAY
YOU'VE GOT A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
TIME TO DETERMINE. WHETHER
WHERE THEY'RE GONNA GO AND
WHETHER THEY'RE APPROPRIATELY
PLACED IN THERE. THEN I THINK
WE GOT IT ABSOLUTELY DEMAND
THAT WE START THE KIND OF
COVERAGE WHICH IS HIGH SPEED.
INTERNET AT A REASONABLE COST
FOR RURAL AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND SO I'M GONNA
SUPPORT THE BILL. BUT I WANT I
WANT A COMMITMENT FROM THE
AUTHOR THAT THESE ARE. ISSUES
THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO HIM AND
FRANKLY THAT FRANKLY THAT
THEY'LL BE REFLECTED IN THE
BILL. BUT THE OTHER PART OF IT
IS THAT TERE ARE A NUMBER OF
INTERNET BILLS AND I HAVE A
FEELING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
PUT. THE PIECES TOGETHER SO
THAT WE GET EVERYTHING THAT WE
NEED. BUT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
THIS MOVING TODAY THAT'S THE
KIND OF COMMITMENT I NEED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SIR
COVER CONSIDER COVER YOU OPENED
WITH US SAYING THAT YOU WANT TO
ASK YOU A QUESTION DID YOU WANT
TO ASK A DIRECT QUESTION OR
WOULD YOU PREFER FOR THE AUTHOR
JUST ADDRESS SO HE CAN HE CAN
ADDRESS IT IN THIS BECAUSE I'M
OKAY WITH THAT. THANK YOU
SENATOR HOW YOU'RE APPRECIATE
THAT- ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS SIDE OF MEMBERS
ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE SENATOR DODD WHICH
LIKE TO CLOSE. YES THAT MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS ON THE FLOOR- I
TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY THIS ISSUE
OF EQUITY TALK TO THE SENATOR
FROM A LOS ANGELES ABOUT THAT
IN THE COMMENTS AND EVERYTHING
REFLECTIVE OF THE SENATOR FROM
SALINAS ARE SPOT ON I MIGHT ADD
THAT- AS I SAID I THINK IN IN
IN MY FLOOR SPEECH. THAT WE
WILL I DON'T THINK A LOT OF THE
CITIES HAVE REALLY BEEN WORKING
ON EQUITY ISSUES WHEN IT COMES
TO CELL SERVICE THE ISSUES OF
MOSTLY BAD WHAT ARE YOU GONNA
PAY ME FOR IT. YEAH WHAT IS
THAT YEAH HOW ARE YOU GONNA
HANG THIS ON THE PULL OF THE
AESTHETICS ALL THOSE THINGS.
AND THE LAST TME THIS BILL WAS
HERE THOSE THEY DIDN'T FEEL
LIKE THIS WAS ADDRESSED WELL
ENOUGH SO THAT'S WHAT WE FOCUS
MOST. IF NOT ALL OF OUR TIME ON
KIND OF GETTING TO WHERE WE ARE
TODAY MY COMMITMENT IS HOLY TO.
REALLY ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IN
THIS BILL- I HAVE NOT EVEN HAD
A DISCUSSION WITH THE
COMMUNICATION AMONG THE CLEAR-
ON THAT TODAY TO DATE. BUT THIS
IS NOT- AT ISSUE JUST FOR
SALINAS OR LOS ANGELES OR SAN
FRANCISCO. IT'S FOR NAPA AND
FAIRFIELD AND VACAVILLE AND ALL
THE KIDS WOULD LINE AND ALL THE
COMMUNITIES. THAT I SERVE SO
IT'S VERY VERY IMPORTANT MAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IBOOK.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD MEMBERS
WERE VOTING ON FILE ITEM FORTY
THREE SENATE BILL FIVE FIFTY
SIX. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA HI AT KINS.
BASE BACKER HI FOR JUST HI
BRADFORD. I HAVE A HI COURTESY
HI DALLY NO DODD I'M SORRY
THERE ARE SO. HI EGGMAN FIVE
GLAZER. GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH HI
HERTZBERG I WISH SO HI HER TADO
HI JONES I CAN LONGER. LAYERED
HI LLEVA I REQUIRE NO MELINDA'S.
MAN FIVE NEWMAN HI NIELSEN HI A
SHOW OF VOGUE. I PAN FIVE
FORTUNE TINO. ROTH HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER. FIVE AMBERG ALL RIGHT
FIVE WACO SKI I WINNER. I WILL
HI SENATOR DODD MOVES A CALL
NEXT WE ARE GOING TO ITEM FORTY
FOUR. WHICH IS- SENATOR
HERTZBERG APPEARS TO BE READY
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL SIX FORTY SIX BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTRICITY CENTERS FOR THE
REMOTEST PRESENCE I MENTION THE
LAST PRESENTATION WE'VE BEEN
GRAPPLING WITH THE DETAILS. OF
HOW TO CONVERT TO A RENEWABLE
ENVIRONMENT THAT'S RELIABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE FOR EVERYONE I AM A
GREAT DISCIPLE OF THE ARCHITECT
MIES VAN DER ROHE WHO ALWAYS
HAS GREAT QUOTE WAS GOD IS IN
THE DETAILS AND WE'RE AT THAT
POINT IN- DEVELOPING POLICY IN
THE ENERGY SPACE TO DEAL WITH
THE DETAILS WE PASSED SB ONE
HUNDRED. A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO
WHICH GRABBED THE HEADLINES
ABOUT WHAT OUR STATE CLIMATE
GOALS WERE THIS BILL BASICALLY
ALIGNS THOSE THE OF THE STATE'S
ELECTRICITY RESOURCE
PROCUREMENT ACTIVITIES WITH THE
STATE CLEAN ENERGY AND
RELIABILITY GOALS I ASKED FOR
AND I VOTE. THANK YOU SIR IS
FOR MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI ACTIONS BATES FIVE
BACKER. HI PORGES HI BRADFORD I
HAVE A AUTO HI CORTEZ. I. DALLY.
HI DODD HI TORONTO HI ADNAN I
GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES HIGH
GROWTH. HI HERTZBERG. TIDO HI
JONES I CAN LONGER. FIVE
LAYERED HI LLEVA I REQUIRE. HI
MELINDA'S I MEN HI NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN I WOULD SHOW A VOGUE HI
PAM HI FORTUNE TINO. ROTH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER BY AMBER ALL
RIGHT HI CASKEY I WINNER HI
WELL. HI. SENATOR MOVE THE
CALL- NEXT WE ARE GOING TO FILE
ITEM FORTY SEVEN WHICH IS
CENTERED BY CAL SKI WHICH WILL
BE FILED FOLLOWED BY FILE IN
FIFTY FIVE CENTER GROVE CENTER
ACCOUNTS HE IS READY SECRETARY
PLEASE COULD. READ SENATE BILL
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI AN ACT RELATING
TO ELECTRICITY. THIS IS THE
RIGHT KELSEY MR PRESENCE OF SP
FOUR THREE SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLAN
SUBMITTED BY PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITIES TO INCLUDE DETAILS OF
AN OF AN ELECTRICITY RATE
DESIGN FOR TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION. SO WHAT DO WE
CARE ABOUT THAT WHY WHY IS THAT
WHAT'S THE BIG DEAL BECAUSE NOW
THESE PLANS DO NOT FULLY%
ADDRESS TRANSPORTATION LIKE FOR
CATION. THEY'RE MOSTLY LIMITED
TO LIGHT DUTY TRUCKS AND THEY
DO NOT INCLUDE MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES SO EXPLICITLY
PROVIDING THAT ALL SECTORS OF
TRANSPORTATION LIKE FOR CATION.
INTO THESE INTEGRATED PLANS
WILL GIVE US YOUR INSURER MORE
COMPREHENSIVE- ELECTRICITY RATE
DESIGN YOU KNOW THE COST. FOR
DOES HAVE TECHNOLOGY FOR BOTH
THE VEHICLES AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT SUPPORTS
THEM IS VITAL FOR- JEFF
ADAPTATION AND- CAN I VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR I. CASKEY YOU
NEED TO OR DEBATE ON BEFORE
THIRTY SO. ANY DISK OR DEBATE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. ARCHULETA I. ATKINS.
BATES NO BACKER. I PORCHES NO
BRADFORD HI COME BETA HI
COURTESY HI DALLY. DODD HI
TORONTO HI ADNAN. FIVE GLAZER
HI CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO- HI HER
TADO HI JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MAN. NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. NO A SHOW OF VOGUE NO
PAN HI FORTUNE TINO. ROTH FIVE
RUBIO HI SKINNER HI AMBERG HI
WHAT KASKY FIVE WINNER HI WILKE.
THANK YOU SARAH CASKEY MOVES A
CALLED MOVING ON TO- FILE ITEM
FIFTY FIVE CENTER GROVE HAS TWO
ITEMS FOR US TODAY CENTER GROVE
IS READY SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION THIRTY FOUR
BY SENATOR GROVE AND THAT'S
REALLY IT RELATIVE TO ARMED
FORCES DAY. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT SR THIRTY FOUR WHICH
COMMENDS MAY FIFTEENTH AS ARMED
FORCES DAY THIS RESOLUTION
RECOGNIZES THE U. S. ARMED
FORCES HISTORY AND HONORS THE
MEN AND WOMEN. WHO HAVE TAKEN
AN OATH TO DEFEND THE UNITED
STATES AT HOME AND ABROAD SINCE
ITS INCEPTION DURING THE
AMERICAN REVOLUTIONARY WAR.
ERIC IS ARMED FORCES PREDATE
THE DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE
WITH THE CREATION OF THE
CONTINENTAL ARMY IN JULY IN
JUNE ON JUNE FOURTEENTH
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE. SINCE
THEN SERVICEMEMBERS HAVE
BRAVELY SERVED AND SACRIFICED
IN ALL SIX CO EQUAL BRANCHES
THE ARMY MARINE CORPS NAVY AIR
FORCE COAST GUARD AND THE
NEWEST BRANCH SPACE FORCE
ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
INTERESTINGLY WHILE THE ARMY
MARINE CORPS AND NAVY TRACE
THEIR ORIGINS TO THEIR
RESPECTIVE CONTINENTAL
PREDECESSORS THE COAST GUARD
AIR FORCE IN SPACE FORCE WERE
ESTABLISHED THROUGH MERGING A
MATERS OF MODERNIZATION AND
VARIOUS DIVISIONS WITHIN THE
ARMED FORCES ALL TO BECOME
INDEPENDENT BRANCHES. IN THEIR
OWN RIGHT THE U. S. AMED
FORCES IS MADE UP OF ONE POINT
THREE SIX MILLION SERVICE
MEMBERS WITH THE D. AN
ADDITIONAL EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND. IN RESERVES AIR FORCE
NATIONAL GUARD AND ARMY
NATIONAL GUARD. AS THE FIRST
FEMALE VETERAN ELECTED TO THIS
LEGISLATURE I'M PROUD TO BRING
THIS LEGISLATION FOR THIS
RESOLUTION BEFORE YOU I'M ALSO
VERY PROUD TO SERVE ON THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON VETERANS
AFFAIRS. WHERE WE HAVE- FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN HISTORY ALL A
UNITED STATES MILITARY VETERANS
SERVING ON THAT COMMITTEE- AND
I AM JUST HONORED TO HAVE THAT
PRIVILEGE TO SERVE WITH MY
DISTINGUISHED COLLEGE
COLLEAGUES IN THAT CAPACITY. S.
R. THIRTY FOUR HONORS THE
HISTORY OF OUR ARMED FORCES AND
SACRIFICES AT EVERY-
SERVICEMEMBER VETERANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND WE WANT TO
THANK EACH AND EVERY ONE OF
THEM. I ALSO WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE CO AUTHORED
AND EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR THIS
RESOLUTION CO AUTHORS INCLUDE-
VETERAN UNITED STATES MILITARY
VETERAN SENATOR ARCHULETA.
UNITED STATES MILLET MILITARY
VETERAN SUSAN EGGMAN UNITED
STATES MILITARY VETERAN MELISSA
MELENDEZ AND UNITED STATES
MILITARY VETERAN COLONEL ROTH
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING S.
R. THIRTY FOUR I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR EITHER. THANK YOU
SENATOR GROVE MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. WE'LL GO
FIRST TO CENTER ARCH ALETTA.
THANK YOU MR. MEMBERS I RISE.
IS IT SHARE. OF THE MILITARY
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE RESOLUTION THIRTY FOUR
RECOGNIZING ARMED FORCES DAY.
I'M PROUD TO RECOGNIZE
INCREDIBLE SACRIFICE THAT OUR
PEOPLE. IN OUR ARMED FORCES
MAKE TODAY AND EACH AND EVERY
DAY. THEIR PATRIOTISM AND
DEDICATION AS PART OF THAT IS
THE MAKE UP IS WHAT TRULY WHAT
MAKES UP AMERICA I KNOW THE
SACRIFICES MADE BY THOSE WHO
SERVE. AND HAVE SERVED AS A
PROUD FATHER OF TWO SONS THAT
ARE SERVING RIGHT NOW ON ACTIVE
DUTY I ALSO RECOGNIZE THEIR
SERVICE AS WELL AS EVERY OTHER.
DAUGHTER AND MOTHER AND
GRANDMOTHER WHO IS SERVING.
GRANDFATHERS UNCLES. THESE ARE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO SERVE
PROUDLY. WITHOUT THE HEROES OF
OUR ARMED FORCES WE WOULD NOT
HAVE THE SAME FREEDOMS WE HAVE
TODAY. THEREFORE I AM PROUD TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF OUR
SERVICEMEN AND WOMEN ONE THING
AND I WANT TO THANK. OUR AUTHOR
FROM BAKERSFIELD AND A VETERAN
HERSELF FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR ARCHULETA CENTER RUBIO.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE
TODAY I ALSO WRITES IN SUPPORT
OF S. R. THIRTY FOUR- I WANT TO
THINK NOT ONLY ALL THOSE THAT
ARE CURRENTLY SERVING AND THOSE
WHO HAVE SERVED. BUT I WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT ALSO TO RECOGNIZE
ALL OUR COLLEAGUES HERE ON THIS
FLOOR AND THERE ARE SEVERAL.
WHO HAVE. SERVED THIS COUNTRY
AND SACRIFICE ON OUR BEHALF AS
KNOW THERE'S MANY SERVICE MEN
AND WOMEN. WHO ARE ON OUR STAFF
STILL WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
RECOGNIZE HIM AS WELL. AS A
MILITARY FAMILY MEMBER MYSELF I
WANT TO THANK ALL THOSE WHO
HAVE. GIVEN OTHER FAMILIES I
KNOW THAT THE SACRIFICES ARE
NOT ONLY FOR THOSE THAT- BUT
THE FAMILY THAT'S LEFT BEHIND
AND- ALSO WANTED KNOWLEDGE
THOSE THAT NEVER GET TO SEE
THEIR LOVED ONES RETURN- IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE- ALWAYS HONOR
THEM NOT ONLY. ON THIS DAY BUT
EVERY OTHER DAY. AND WITH THAT
I'D URGE AND I VOTE AS WELL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM MEMBERS ANY
OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CENTER GROVE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
WOULD LIKE TO ALSO ADD THAT
SENATORS AMBERG UNITED STATES
MILITARY VETERAN AND BERG AND
UNITED STATES MILITARY VETERAN.
JOSH NEWMAN ALSO ADDED- TO THIS
RESOLUTION- AND WE'LL MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR NAMES GET ON IT AT
THE NEXT POSSIBLE DATE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPO
THANK YOU SENATOR GROVE-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WITH ALAN. I ARCHULETA HI AT
KINS. BASE I BACKER. FIVE FOUR
JUST HI BRADFORD HI COME BY
OTHER HI CORTESE HI DALLY I DON.
THE RISER HI ADNAN HI GLAZER.
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HI GROSS
FIVE HURTS BERG HI WITH SO. HI
HER TADO FIVE JONES I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED I LIVE THAT I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S I MEN. BY
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. FIVE A SHOW
OF BOTH HI PAM FIVE FORTUNE
TINO. ROTH HI RUBIO. FIVE
SKINNER HI AMBERG RIGHT HI
RIGHT BECAUSE HE FIVE WINNERS
HI WELL. CENTER GROVE WAS THE
CALL CENTER GROWS UP NEXT ALSO
ON ITEM FIFTY SIX S. R. THIRTY
FIVE LOOKS LIKE CENTER GROVE'S
READY SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION THIRTY FIVE
BY SENATOR GROWTH RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
MEMORIAL DAY. CENTER GROVE
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SR
THIRTY FIVE COMMEMORATES MAY
FIFTEENTH AS PEACE OFFICERS
MEMORIAL DAY. MAY FIFTEENTH IS
A COMBINATION OF A WEEK OF
REMEMBRANCE AND FELLOWSHIP
EVENTS HONORING THE LIVES OF
THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO DIED IN
SERVICE TO OUR COMMUNITIES IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE NOT ONLY
RECOGNISE BUT UNDERSTAND THE
RESPONSIBILITIES HAZARDS AND
IMMENSE SACRIFICES LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS BEAR EACH
AND EVERY DAY. IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT THAT WE RECOGNIZE THE
LEVEL ONES THAT HAVE GUIDED
ENCOURAGED AND SUPPORTED THEM
ALONG THE WAY. TODAY OUR POLICE
OUR POLICE OFFICERS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS FACE A GREAT AMOUNT
OF UNCERTAINTY THEY'RE SUBJECT%
TO MATCH GREEN TEA AND
CONDEMNATION YET THEY CONTINUE
TO PROTECT AND UPHOLD THE LAWS
THAT BENEFIT ALL INCLUDING
THOSE THAT ARE AGAINST THEM. IN
A SINGLE DAY AN OFFICER MAY
RESPOND TO CALLS FOR A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE INCIDENT DEADLY CAR
ACCIDENTS OR A PERSON ON TOP OF
THE BRIDGE CONTEMPLATING
SUICIDE. WHEN AN OFFICER
RESPONDS TO A CALL PULL SOMEONE
OVER KNOCKS ON THE DOOR OR
ENTERS A SCENE. THEY HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT SCENARIO AWAITS THEM.
AND THEY MUST BE READY AT ALL
TIMES TO PERFORM THEIR DUTIES
THE DUTIES OF A POLICE OFFICER
ARE ARD TO DEFINE WITH SO MUCH
UNCERTAINTY IN THEIR DAY NOT
ONE DAY IS THE SAME AS THE
NEXT. FROM TIME TO TIME THEY
PUT THEIR UNIFORM ON AND THEY
LEAVE THEIR HOMES THEY HAVE NO
IDEA IF THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO RETURN HOME TO THEIR
FAMILY THAT EVENING. THEY WORK
WEEKENDS CHRISTMASES AND MOST
ALL HOLIDAYS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN ENJOY SAFETY IN OUR
COMMUNITY. OUR COMMUNITY HOLDS
POLICE OFFICERS AT A HIGHER
STANDARD AT ALL TIMES EVEN
THOUGH THEY MAY TAKE THEIR
UNIFORM IN THEIR BADGE OFF AT
THE END OF THE DAY WHEN
RETURNING HOME. THE DUTY TO
SERVE IS NEVER LAID TO REST.
OUR PEACE OFFICERS HAVE A JOB
SECOND IN IMPORTANCE TO NINE
AND IT'S A JOB THAT IS
DIFFICULT AS DANGEROUS AND
DANGEROUS AS IT IS IMPORTANT.
OUR CALIFORNIA POLICE OFFICERS
HAVE WORKED DUTIFULLY AND
SELFLESSLY ON BEHALF OF THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA REGARDLESS OF THE
PERIL AND THE HAZARD TO
THEMSELVES. IT'S IMPERATIVE
THAT WE ALWAYS RECOGNIZE THEIR
SACRIFICE. WE MUST DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN WITHIN OUR
POWER TO HONOR THEMEMORY AND
THE LEGACY OF OUR FALLEN
OFFICERS. WE MUST ENSURE THAT
OUR FELLOW CALIFORNIANS
REMEMBER THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE GIVEN THEIR LIVES FOR OUR
SAFETY. AND EXPRESS EXPRESS
APPRECIATION TO THOSE WHO
CONTINUE TO DEDICATE THEIR
LIVES TO MAKING CALIFORNIA
SAFER PLACE TO LIVE AND RAISE
THEIR FAMILIES. WE THINK THE
POLICE OFFICERS AND OUR PEACE
OFFICERS WHO SERVE TODAY AND
THOSE WHO DIED GIVING THEIR ALL
AND DIED DURING THE SERVICE OF
THEIR COMMUNITY. ON MONDAY
SHERIFF MIKE BOUDREAUX TULARE
COUNTY INVITED ME TO BE THE
KEYNOTE SPEAKER AT A MEMORIAL
SERVICE FOR THOSE THAT LOST
THEIR LIVES IN TWENTY TWENTY.
THE SHERIFF MY CELL AND THE
CHIEF OF THE TO TELERI COUNTY
ARE SKEWED ME TO LEARN POLICE
TO. ALSO SPOKE AND WE STOOD
BEFORE A MARBLE WALL THAT ON
THAT WALL AXED FROM EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY NINE TO TWENTY TWENTY
WERE NAMES OF OFFICERS THAT HAD
LOST THEIR LIFE. THE TWO
OFFICERS THAT WERE SPECIFICALLY
HONORED ALL WERE HONORED AND
REMEMBERED BUT THE TWO
SPECIFICALLY THAT LOST THEIR
LIVES IN TWENTY TWENTY. WERE
FLANKED FRANKLIN LUTHER ARNOLD.
FROM THE OFFICE OF PROTECTIVE
SERVICES INTO WATCH DATE WAS
JANUARY TWENTY SECOND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND DEPUTY FRANK G.
HOLD DEAN THE THIRD. TELERI
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
INTO WATCH WAS JANUARY TWENTY
SEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE. BOTH
OF THESE DISTINGUISHED OFFICERS
THAT PROTECTED THAT COMMUNITY
DIED OF COMPLICATIONS OF COPD
NINETEEN. AND THEIR NAMES WILL
BE FOREVER ETCHED IN THAT WALL
INTO LARRY- RIGHT NEXT TO THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE. AND WE HOPE
THAT THEIR SACRIFICE AND THE
WORK THAT THEY DID FOR OUR
COMMUNITY WILL NEVER BE
FORGOTTEN I RESPECTFULLY
ASPIRIN I VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR GROVE MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE. WE'LL GO
FIRST TO SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU MR. AT TEN I WANT TO RISE
SINCE OF S. HEART. FIVE I WANNA
REVISE BECAUSE I KNOW THAT- OUR
PEACE OFFICERS ALSO SACRIFICE A
LOT. I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
AS A SURVIVOR OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PEACE OFFICERS HAVE
BECOME VERY IMPORTANT TO SOME
OF THE VICTIMS OUT THERE.
THEY'RE THE ONLY ONES STANDING
BETWEEN THE VICTIM AND THEIR
ABUSERS SO WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE
THAT EVERY DAY THAT THEY GO OUT
TO A CALL THEY PUT THEIR LIVES
AT RISK. I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT-
STOCKTON POLICE OFFICER JIMMY
N. WHO WAS SHOT AND KILLED
EARLY TUESDAY MORNING WHILE
RESPONDING TO A CALL OF A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE- HE WAS A
HUSBAND. AND A FATHER AND HE
LEAVES BEHIND NOT ONLY HIS WIFE
BUT A SEVEN MONTH OLD BABY. AND
THAT BREAKS MY HEART BECAUSE
THERE'S ALSO A FAMILY BEHIND.
THIS GENTLEMEN AND EVERY OTHER
OFFICER THAT LOSES THEIR LIVES
IN THE LINE OF DUTY. SO AGAIN I
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT THEY MEAN TO
SURVIVORS. VICTIMS AND EVERY
OTHER OBJECT I'M OUT THERE- SO
AGAIN I STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT
AND URGE AN EYEFUL THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO CENTER.
ARCH ALETTA FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
EDMUND. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
RESOLUTION THIRTY FIVE
RECOGNIZING PEACE OFFICERS. IN
THE MEMORIAL DAY FOR THEM R. P.
SHOP SHOULD PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES EVERY SINGLE DAY
DIFFICULT AND DANGEROUS WORK.
AND TOO OFTEN LIVES ARE LOST IN
SERVICE KEEPING OUR COMMUNITY
SAFE. WE ARE DEAD TO THOSE WHO
PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE
EVERY SINGLE DAY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THEY WEAR THE BADGE
OF HONOR THEY WEAR THE UNIFORM.
THEY WEAR TO SUPPORT AND
PROTECT. COMMUNITY AFTER
COMMUNITY. AS A FORMER LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER MYSELF I
COULD SHARE WITH YOU THE NUMBER
OF. MEMORIALS THAT I'VE BEEN
TO. IN TO SEE THE FAMILIES THE
FAMILIES JUST. HUGGING ONE
ANOTHER FALLING APART BECAUSE
THEY JUST LOST THEIR BROTHER.
THEIR HUSBAND THEIR WIFE THE
GRANDMOTHER AND AUNT IS A
FAMILY MEMBER. WHEN THE TWENTY
ONE GUN SALUTE GOES BEST
SALUDOS OFF TAPS FOLDING OF THE
FLAG IT IS HEART BREAKING. BUT
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO SERVE IN
EVERY SINGLE DAY WE LOOK TO
MORE AND MORE MEN AND WOMEN TO
JOIN LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT WE
ASKED THE BEST. WE WOULD
REQUEST THE BEST. BUT WE GIVE
UP OUR BEST IN FOR THESE
REASONS I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
THANK YOU SAID ARCHULETA CENTER
ADMIN FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
BRADFORD CENTER AGAIN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I JUST ALSO
LIKE TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION. AND WHILE DOING A
GERMAN MEMORY HAD A FUTURE
DATE. SENATOR RUBIO POINTED OUT
OF. STOCKTON POLICE DEPARTMENT
LOST AN OFFICER. THIS WEEK.
AFTER GIVING IT ON WAS TO THEM
BY FUNK IT TENA IN THE- WITH A
WOMAN WITH THEIR CLOTHES ENOUGH
EIGHT YEAR OLD BEING STRONG.
AND ROLLED UP ON THAT SCENE AND
SELFLESSLY JUMPED OUT OF THAT
CAR AND WAS SHOT AND KILLED- WE
MOURN FOR HIS FAMILY FOR THE%
COMMUNITY. BY ALL REPORTS HE
WAS A KIND OF OFFICER EVERYBODY
WANTS ON THE STREETS YOUNG
CAMBODIAN. MAN WHO WANTED TO
GET BACK TO HIS COMMUNITY. AS
WE AS WE- THIS ISSUE TO. IN
TALKING THAT DOES THIS THING
ABOUT THE VERY. REAL DANGER
THAT OFFICER ON THE STREETS
EVERY SINGLE DAY AS THEY BURN
OUT AND TRY TO DO THEIR BEST TO
KEEP US SAFE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER ADMIN CENTER
BRADFORD FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
NIELSEN. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AS YOUR PUBLIC SAFETY I TOO
WANT TO RISE AND- SUPPORT OF S.
R. THIRTY FIVE AND REMEMBER AND
HONOR. THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO DO
A DIFFICULT JOB. IN MANY WAYS A
THANKLESS JOB BUT NONE THE LESS
ANHONORABLE JOB OF PROTECTING
AND SERVING IN THE MAJORITY OF
THOSE MEN AND WOMEN DO IT
SELFISHLY. ON A DAILY BASIS
WITHOUT ANY CONSIDERATION OF
THEIR PERSONAL WRIST AT TIMES.
SO WE DO WANT TO RECOGNIZE THEM
WE APPRECIATE ON. AN AS A
INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS RELATIVES AS
WELL AS GOOD FRIENDS WHO HAVE
SERVED IN LAW ENFORCEMENT I
KNOW. THE SACRIFICES THAT THEY
MAKE EVERY DAY I KNOW THE
COMMITMENT THAT THEY MAKE. WHEN
THEY PUT THAT UNIFORM ON AND AS
I STATED THE MAJORITY OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS DO IT IN A MATTER
OF WHICH WE CAN ALL BE PROUD OF
AND WE ALL FEEL BETTER AND WE
ALL. ARE BETTER BECAUSE OF WHAT
THEY DO ON A DAILY BASIS SO. I
DO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU WITH A
DEEP SENSE OF GRATITUDE TO THE
WOMEN MEN AND WOMEN WHO PROTECT
AND SERVE A MORE IMPORTANT TO
THOSE WHO. LOST THEIR LIVES
JUST AS WE HAVE STATED- OFFICER
JIMMY AND WHO LOST HIS LIFE
JUST TWO DAYS AGO AND STOPPED
AND- HE CLEARLY EXAMPLE FOUGHT
EXEMPLIFIES. THE BEST OF THE
BEST WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO. STRONG THAT'S
RIVAL. THANK YOU READ FOR
SENATOR. FOLLOWED BY SOME LAYER.
THE LADIES AND GENTS THE SET.
HI TO RAW. TO A- THESE LAWS.
LOVED ONES. THESE BRAVE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO EVERY DAY GET UP. NOT
KNOWING. IF THEY'RE GONNA COME
HOME THAT EVENING. IT IS WELL
THEIR FAMILIES WHO SIMILARLY.
HAVE TO WONDER. I'VE BEEN TO
ALL TOO MANY. THE SERVICES.
THEN I GRIEVE EVERY TIME I GO
AND IT LINGERS WITH ME FOR A
FEW DAYS AFTERWARDS AS I THINK.
ABOUT THAT INDIVIDUAL THAT MAN
THAT WOMAN. WHO WENT ON THEIR
WATCH. HOPEFUL CONFIDENT WELL
TRAINED OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSIONALS IN AMERICA ARE
THE BEST TRAINED IN THE WORLD.
IT DAILY THEY DO WHAT I CALL
AND WHAT HAS BEEN CALLED RANDOM
ACTS OF KINDNESS. THE TINY
LITTLE THINGS THAT ARE A LITTLE
BIT BEYOND THE JOB DESCRIPTION.
THAT THEY DO THAT ANYWAY. THE
HURLING THINGS THAT SAVE
PEOPLE'S LIVES. I'VE SEEN THEM
COMING OUT HOLDING THE CHILD.
AND HANDING THAT CHILD TO THE
MOTHER WATCHING HER BREAK DOWN
WEEPING. THAT OUR CHILD I WOULD
SAVE. THE THERMAL AGING
KNOWLEDGE IN THESE OFFICERS ARE
VERY MOVIE. WHAT ARE THE LAST
THINGS THAT OCCURS IN A
CEREMONY. IS A RECORDING.
COMING IN FROM A DISPATCHER.
ANNOUNCING THE END OF WATCH. OF
THAT OFFICER. EDITOR'S
SACRAMENTAL SERVICE. IN THE
LAST YEAR. I EXPERIENCE
SOMETHING NEW. THAT WAS VERY
PRECIOUS. AFTER THE CEREMONY
AND THE END OF WATCH. IN THE
LAST MOMENTS. A CANINE GROUP
BEGIN BARKING FROM SOMEWHERE WE
COULDN'T REALLY SEE WHERE THEY
WERE. BUT THESE KIND K. NINE
UNITS. WORKING KNOWLEDGE YOU.
THAT FALLEN OFFICERS. AND ONE
THING WE DON'T OFTEN THINK
ABOUT WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE
PEACE OFFICERS MEMORIAL. AND I
HADN'T BEEN ALL THE ONES THAT
CEREMONIES THAT I HAD BEEN TO.
A FEW YEARS AGO IN MY OFFICE AT
A GROUP OF THE FAMILIES OF.
SLAIN OFFICERS WE LOST ONE. IN
THE AREA THAT I REPRESENT. THEY
WERE ALL IN THE OFFICE. AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE PEACE
OFFICERS MEMORIAL. AND WHAT A
HOLY AND PRECIOUS EXPERIENCE
THAT IS. WHEN I GO BACK MANY
TIMES ALONE. AND BECAUSE- THE
PRICE. BUT SHE SAID WELL.
SENATOR WHAT ABOUT ME. MY
HUSBAND'S NAME CAN'T GO UP ON
THAT WALL. AND I LOOKED INTO
WONDERING ALL RIGHT TOWARDS HER
AND WHAT WAS SHE SAYING. AND
THEN I CAME TO ME. I SAID
SUICIDE. SUICIDE YES THAT
REFLECTS THE MANY. AND WE DON'T
RECOGNIZE THOSE WHO DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THOSE. BUT THEIR
SACRIFICE IS GREAT I ASK THAT
YOU MY COLLEAGUES AS WE HONOR
THESE FALLEN OFFICERS TODAY.
REMEMBER SOME OF THOSE. WHO
ENDED THEIR LIVES. YEAH HEY
GIVE ME. AS SUICIDES. THANK YOU
SENATOR NELSON CENTER LAYERED
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR DELHI SAID
EARLIER THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF OUR SR
THIRTY FIVE AND JUST AS MY
COLLEAGUES THAT REPRESENT SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY THIS WEEK WE
LOST DETECTIVE LUCA BENEDETTI
OF THE SAN LUIS OBISPO POLICE
DEPARTMENT WHILE HE WAS.
SERVING A SEARCH WARRANT. HE
LEAVES BEHIND A WIFE AND TWO
YOUNG CHILDREN HE SERVED EIGHT
YEARS ON THE SAN LUIS OBISPO
POLICE DEPARTMENT FOR YEARS
BEFORE ON THE ATASCADERO POLICE
DEPARTMENT. AND THE ROLE OF
HONOR THAT WAS JUST MENTIONED
WILL ALSO HAVE ADDED THIS YEAR
LIEUTENANT DAMON GUTS WHY WERE
FROM THE SANTA CRUZ SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT I DID IN A GERMAN
MEMORY- RECENTLY FOR HIM. AND
HE WAS AMBUSHED BY AN EXTREMIST
IN THE SANTA CRUZ MOUNTAINS WHO
IS NOW ALLEGED TO HAVE KILLED A
FEDERAL OFFICER IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY A COUPLE OF DAYS BEFORE.
AND IT WAS VERY MOVING AT HIS
MEMORIAL BECAUSE- ARE HE HAS A
CHILD THAT WAS BORN AFTER HIS
DEATH. WHO WILL NEVER KNOW HIS
FATHER. AND SO IN THEIR
MEMORIES ARE BIASED FEARFUL.
THANK YOU SENATOR LAYERED-
SENATOR DELHI. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I ALSO. ON A
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SR THIRTY
FIVE I JUST A LOT OF COMMENTS
TODAY- ALL VERY ACCURATE AND I
WANT TO SAY THAT SOMEBODY HAS
FAMILY MEMBERS THAT- ARE DOING
LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT THE. WHAT
WHAT SENATOR NELSON BROUGHT UP
ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH OF OUR
OFFICERS EXTENDS ALSO TO THE
FAMILIES. IN THE LAST YEAR
WE'VE SEEN. A LOT OF
CONTROVERSIES IN OUR NATION AND
OUR STATE AND THEY'VE BEEN
CALLED TO DUTY ANALYST DAY
AFTER DAY AND SO I JUST WANNA
SHARE THAT- ALSO GOES OUT TO
THOSE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO. HAVE
TO WATCH THEIR LOVED ONES GO
OUT EVERY DAY AND DO THE CALL
OF DUTY. AND THOSE OF US WHO
HAVE HAD I'M I'M SURE EVERYBODY
ON THE FLOOR- HAS ATTENDED ONE
OF THE SERVICES AND WATCHING
THE- AND THE THINGS THAT HAPPEN
AT THOSE THIS IS HEART
WRENCHING SO I ALSO TO WIN WIN
MY SUPPORT TO. ALL THOSE WHO
PROTECT US EVERY DAY- WITHOUT
TONE. RESERVATION JUST DOING IT
AND- AND THE FAMILIES AS LONG
AS WELL THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR DELHI.
MEMBERS AS ANY OTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
GROVE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
PLEASE THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL MY
COLEAGUES ON THE FLOOR WHO
MADE SUCH HEARTFELT REMARKS-
HONORING- OUR PEACE OFFICERS
COLLEAGUES- THESE HEROES WERE
HUSBANDS WIVES- THE MOTHERS
FATHERS SONS AND DAUGHTERS THEY
WERE FAMILIES- A PART OF OUR
FAMILY THEY WERE FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS. ONE MINUTE THEY'RE
STANDING WITH US CHEERING AT AFOOTBALL GAME AND THEN HOURS
LATER THEY'RE ON PATROL
RESPONDING TO A CALL AND SURE
IF THEY'LL BE MAKING AT HOME-
FROM WORK THAT DAY. SO I THANK
YOU FOR THIS RESOLUTION AND
SUPPORTING IT AND IT'S TO HONOR
THOSE THAT SERVE OUR COMMUNITY
AND MAKE SURE THAT- THEIR
BRAVERY AND COURAGE WILL ALWAYS
BE HONORED AND NEVER FORGOTTEN
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
NIGHT OUT. THANK YOU SENATOR OF
MEMBERS AS A FATHER OF A POLICE
OFFICER I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS THIS MORNING AND
THANK YOU FOR THEM- THIS ITEM
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
THE. USE OF UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ON THIS ITEM. C. NONE. I THIRTY
SIX KNOWS. THE MAJOR. THANK YOU
SIR MEMBERS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO LIFTING THE CALL I
BELIEVE. AND WE ARE GOING TO
START WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE.
AND IF THE SECRETARY COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I'M SORRY
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN I
BABIES. ADMIN FIVE. A TOTAL OF
A. THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
VOTE IS TWENTY NINE EYES NOSE
SEVEN THE APPOINTEE IS
CONFIRMED MOVING ON TO FILE AN
M. FIFTY ONE S. C. R. FORTY
FOUR- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
UP SOME MEMBERS. EGGMAN HI.
THIRTY EIGHT EYES NO ZERO MAJOR
PASSES. I'M SORRY. I'M SORRY
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MOVING ON
TO- FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE S. C.
R. TWENTY THREE ARCHULETA
PLEASE CALL THE OPTION NUMBERS.
ADMIN HI RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY I'M SORRY THE VOTE IS-
THIRTY SEVEN TO ZERO. I'M
WAITING FOR TO SHOW UP THIRTY
EIGHT. NEXT IS- FOR. THIRTEEN
FILE I'M THIRTEEN ARCHULETA SP.
THREE NINETY TWO. PLEASE CALL
THE UP SOME NUMBERS. ADMIN I
GROVE. WHITE HOUSE SKI. THIRTY
SIX EYES NO ZERO MAJOR PASSES
FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE SP THREE
FORTY ONE REQUIRE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. FAITH I.
EGGMAN I JONES. THIRTY SEVEN
ZERO MAJOR PASSES FILE AND I'M
THIRTY NINE AS BEFORE FORTY
THREE HERZBERG PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THIRTY NINE
THIRTY NINE HERTZBERG. KELLY
ABSENT MEMBERS PLEASE. FOR JUST.
EGGMAN HI. HIGHS THIRTY ONE NO
SIX MAJOR PASSES FILE AND I'M
FORTY THREE S. B. FIVE FIFTY
SIX SENATOR DODD PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN. AT
KINS I BASED. GLAZER CAN LONGER.
MELINDA'S FORTUNE TINO. HI
HIGHS THIRTY ONE KNOWS TO
MEASURE PASSES FILE AND M.
FORTY FOUR S. BE SIX FORTY SETS
SIX SP SIX FORTY SIX HERZBERG
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AT KINS. I FORTUNE TINO. I.
THIRTY TWO ZERO MAJOR PASSES
ITEM FORTY SEVEN FILE IN FORTY
SEVEN SP FOUR THIRTY SEVEN
RIGHT CASKEY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN I. ATKINS
I. DALLY NO GROWTH. NO MEN I
FORTUNE TINO I WILKE. HI IS
TWENTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT MAJOR
PASSES. FINAL ON CALL IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY FIVE S. R.
THIRTY FOUR CENTER GROVE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. AT
KINS I. THE CARD. I. FORTUNE
TINO THE I. WELL RESOLUTIONS
ABOUT. SEVEN HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN
NO ZERO MAJOR PASSES PRIME
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. AND WE'VE
GOT A COUPLE OF ITEMS ON
CONSENT. DOES ANY MEMBER WISH
TO PULL ANYTHING OFF OF CONSENT.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. I DID.
SENATE BILLS AT. 594-396-5776.
296-404-7337. FIFTY THREE EIGHT
THIRTEEN EIGHT FOURTEEN EIGHT
TWENTY SEVEN AND SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION. TWENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED- 30% WELL
I'M SORRY. LET'S CALL THE ROLL
ON CONSENT BEFORE WE SAY IT'S
ADOPTED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA I AT KINS BY
BATES HI BECKER. HI PORGES FIVE
BRADFORD I HAVE A HI CORTESE HI
DALLY. DALLY FIVE DODD. HI
TORONTO HI ADNAN I BLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES BY GROWTH HI HERZ
BERG. HI WITH SO. HI FURTADO HI
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI
LLEVA I REQUIRE. I MELINDA'S I
MEN. I NEWMAN HI NIELSEN HI A
TRIO OF BOTH HI PAM. HI PERSON
TINA. I BROUGHT HI RUBIO. HI HI
SKINNER HI AMBERG ALL RIGHT HI
WHAT CASKEY FIVE WINNER. I WILL.
THANK YOU AGAIN SINCE IT CAN
SINK COUNTERS THIRTY SEVEN EYES
NO ZEROS THAT CAN SING
CALENDARS ADOPTED MEMBERS ARE
MOVING ON TO THE SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE TWO
ITEMS ON THE SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR DOES ANY MEMBER WISH
TO CALL EITHER ONE OF THOSE
ITEMS. SECRETARY PLEASE READ
THE SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TWENTY SIX AND
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BASE HI
BECKER. HI FOR JUST. BRADFORD I
HAVE A- HI CORTEZ HE HI DALLY.
HI DODD HI THERE ARE SO. HI
ADNAN. HI GLAZER FIVE DOLLARS
FIVE GROWTH. HI HERTZBERG HI
WITH SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S BY MEN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. HI A SHOW OF
BOTH HI PAM HI FORTUNE TINO HI
ROTH HI RUBIO. I SKINNER.
AMBERG HI WHAT KASKY. HI WINNER
HI WELL. PLEASE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. PORGES I
SKINNER WELL. SPECIAL CONSENT
KELLER'S THIRTY SIX EYES NO
ZERO MEASURE PASSES OR CAN SING
COUNTERS ADOPTED MEMBERS WERE
GONNA GO THE PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. SENATOR PAN IS
REQUESTING TO BE RECOGNIZED
SENATOR PAM THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- CENTERS- TODAY I
WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE AND
WELCOME TO THE SENATE TO UP IN
THE GALLERY DR RUSTY- AND A
GROUP OF VOLUNTEERS FROM
EQUIFAX. EQUIFAX WAS FORMED AS
A COLLABORATION BETWEEN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY REGIONAL
LEADERS AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WITH THE GOAL OF
CHANGING THE DEMOGRAPHICS
VACCINATION IN THE SACRAMENTO
AREA. DR AND THIS GROUP OF
EQUIFAX VOLUNTEERS INCLUDING
DOCTORS NURSES FIREFIGHTERS
EMTS AND MANY OTHERS HAVE BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN NOT ONLY
HOLDING THE TWO VACCINE CLINICS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL. BUT
HELPING VACCINATE OUR MEMBERS
INSTEAD HELPING TO VACCINATE
OUR MEMBERS OF STAFF AGAINST
COVE IN NINETEEN BUT THEY HAVE
HELD CLINICS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTY PROVIDING ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND VACCINE SO FAR. WITH
MAJOR CLINICS TAKING PLACE IN
HISTORICALLY UNDER RESOURCE
COMMUNITIES PLEASE GIVE. THEM A
WARM SET WELCOME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DR PAN AND ALL OF OUR
GUESTS IN THE GALLERY THNK YOU
FOR YOUR EXCELLENT WORK THIS
MORNING WE APPRECIATE IT.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA GO TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS WE HAVE
ONE MEMBER REQUESTING TO BE
RECOGNIZED FOR MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS CENTER MELINDA'S.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT PURSUANT
TO SENATE RULE TWENTY EIGHT I
AM MAKING A MOTION AGAIN TO
WITHDRAW AS SIERRA FIVE. FROM
THE SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE AND
BROUGHT TO THE FLOOR. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IT HAS BEEN FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX DAYS NOW
SINCE THE GOVERNOR DECLARED A
STATE OF EMERGENCY. AND SHUT
DOWN THE STATE FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY SIX DAYS. OF TEMPORARY
MEASURES CONTINUING- I WOULD
ASK THAT YOU REFLECT ON THAT
REFLECT ON THE FACT THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIAN CAN NOW RECEIVE A
VACCINE SHOULD THEY CHOOSE TO
GET ONE. REFLECT ON THE FACT
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS STATED.
THAT JUNE FIFTEENTH WILL BE THE
DAY THE CALIFORNIA RE OPENS IN
ITS ENTIRETY FOR BUSINESS. I
REFLECT ON WHETHER OR NOT THIS
EMERGENCY ORDER IS STILL NEEDED
WITH THAT I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU SIR
MELINDA'S CENTERS BERG FOR
CHRISTY RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR PRESIDENT SET THE
MAJORITY LEADER ASKS FOR A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTERS FOR EXTENDER MILLIS IS
ASKING FOR AN I. VOTE SENATOR
HERTZBERG IS ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN NO ARCHULETA NO
ATKINS NO BATES. I THANK. NO
FOR JUST HI BRADFORD NO COME BY
AND I'LL- NO CORTESE NO DALLY I
DON WELL NO TORONTO NO ADMIN.
NO GLAZER. NO GUNS ALLAH'S NO
GROWTH HI HERTZBERG NO WAY SO.
NO HER TADO. NO JONES I CAN
LONGER NO LAYERED NO LLEVA NO
MCGUIRE NO MELINDA'S I MEN. NO
NEWMAN NO NIELSEN. HI A SHOW OF
OAK. HI PAM. NO PERSON TO YOU
KNOW- NO ROTH. NO RUBIO NO
SKINNER. NO AMBERG NO WAY
CASKEY NO WINNER NO WELL. SIZE
EIGHT NOS TWENTY NINE MOTION
FAILS. I SEE SENATOR LAYERED
WANTING TO BE RECOGNIZED
LAYERED NO NOT TOLD COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCED. THANK YOU SIR- WELL
WE WILL MOVE ON TO COMMUNITY
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS AND NOW%
WE'LL RECOGNIZE SINNER LAYERED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE EDUCATION AND
SUBCOMMITTEE THREE ON HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES WILL HAVE A
JOINT HEARING UPON ADJOURNMENT
IN FORTY TWO OH THREE. THANK
YOU SIR EARLIER CENTER DRAWS A
WE HAVE THE SAME- SENATE BUT-
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE. TEN MINUTES
AFTER GERMAN OF SESSION BUT- I
HAVE FORTY TWO OH THREE I HAVE
YOU IN THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
OKAY ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE.
SORRY SORRY THAT WAS IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE THANK YOU
SANDRA'S A CENTER WHERE IT IS
IN FORTY TWO OR THREE CENTER
DRAWS ALWAYS IN THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE. I BELIEVE. THAT
WRAPS UP OUR BUSINESS FOR THE
DAY IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS SENATOR BATES. I'M
SORRY. I'M SORRY. WE'RE GONNA
HURT MEMBERS ARE GONNA RETURN
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AND
WE HAVE THREE ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY WE'RE GOING TO RECOGNIZE
CENTER CORTESE FIRST CENTER
CORTESE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
IT'S WITH DEEP SADNESS THAT
ARISE NOW SEND IT TO CHURN THE
MEMORY OF CHARLES W. DAVIDSON-
MANY PEOPLE KNEW HIM AS CHARLIE
DAVIDSON OR CHUCK DAVIDSON- I
ALWAYS REFERRED TO HIM AS MR
DAVIDSON- HE WAS A HOUSING
DEVELOPER AND PHILANTHROPIST
WITH A CLEAR DESIRE TO HELP SAN
JOSE'S. MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS. HIS JOURNEY STARTED
MODESTLY HE CAME TO SAN JOSE AT
TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD WITH
LITTLE MONEY TO SPARE HE JOINED
UNITED STATES AIR FORCE FOR A
BRIEF PERIOD AND THEN BEGAN TO
ATTEND CLASSES. AS SOON AS THE
STATE UNIVERSITY DURING THE DAY
WHILE WORKING AT THE LOCAL RAIL
YARD DURING THE NIGHT. HE
EVENTUALLY BECAME AN EXTREMELY
SUCCESSFUL DEVELOPER IN HELMS
SEVERAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS. THROUGH HIS
DEVELOPMENT FIRM. CHARLES SOFT
WILL. AS WITH THE COMMUNITY
TRULY NEEDED HE NEVER ONCE.
NEVER ONCE CONVERTED A LOW
INCOME UNITS. TO MARKET RATE
HOUSING. IN ADDITION TO HIS
WORK ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING. HE
GAVE CONSIDERABLE AMOUNTS OF
MONEY BACK TO THE COMMUNITY HE
FREQUENTLY GAVE TO LOCAL
CHARITIES ANONYMOUSLY IN NEARLY
WOULD GIVE TO A LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS FOR THE DAVIDSON
FAMILY FOUNDATION. ONE OF HIS
MOST NOTABLE ACTS. WAS HIS
DONATION OF FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY THE LARGEST PRIVATE
DONATION IN THE SCHOOL'S
HISTORY. MR DAVIDSON WAS TRULY
AN ALTRUISTIC PERSON WHO CARED
DEEPLY FOR THE WELL BEING OF
THIS COMMUNITY. HE WILL BE
DEEPLY MISSED NOT JUST BY. HIS
FRIENDS AND FAMILY- WHO THOSE
WE LEAVE BEHIND. HIS BUSINESS
PARTNERS. ALL OF US IN PUBLIC
SERVICE IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY-
AND THE LARGER COMMUNITY HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE NEEDED
CHILDREN BILL AND STEPHANIE AND
SIX GRANDCHILDREN. IN A
RESPECTFUL YES THE SENATE
JOINED. IN THE MEMORY OF
CHARLES W. DAVIDSON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MR PRESIDENT IT ISN'T OFTEN
MEMBERS THAT A SINGLE HUMAN
BEING FOR THEIR SELFLESS
CONTRIBUTION AND SHEER FORCE OF
PERSONALITY CAN EMBED
THEMSELVES INTO THE VERY
CHARACTER OF A PLACE THE SOUL
OF THE COMMUNITY. ON APRIL
TWENTY EIGHTH TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE WE LOST SUCH AN
INDIVIDUAL HER NAME THE FIRST
LADY OF THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
JANE BOCKMAN. ALL WHO KNEW HER
COULD ATTEST TO JANE'S TOWERING
PERSONALITY AND MATCHLESS
CHARISMA OR STAPLE OF MY
COMMUNITY IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY FOR OVER HALF A CENTURY.
SHE MOVED TO LOS ANGELES FROM
MY HOME TOWN OF VAN BUREN
ARKANSAS AT THE AGE OF ELEVEN.
AND EXCELLED IN LOS ANGELES
PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN DECIDING TO
PURSUE A UNIVERSITY IN
EDINBURGH SCOTLAND. IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SIX SHE MARRIED HER
HUSBAND BERT BACHMANN AND
TOGETHER AND I MEAN TOGETHER
THEY WERE A TEAM THEY BUILT ONE
OF THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
AUTOMOBILE DEALERSHIP BUSINESS
THE WORLD GALPIN MOTORS. WHICH
THE FORD DEALERSHIP AMONG THE
MANY IS THE LARGEST IN THE
COUNTRY I THINK IN THE WORLD
ACTUALLY. FOR DECADES CHANGE
SERVICE TREASURER AND CORPORATE
DIRECTOR FOR THE COMPANY
BUILDING CAPTAIN MOTORS AS I
SUGGESTED TO THE LARGEST
HIGHEST VOLUME FORD DEALERSHIP
IN THE WORLD. WELL SHE HELD THE
POST SHE ALSO FOUNDED VALLEY
MAGAZINE SERVING AS PUBLISHER
AND EDITOR IN CHIEF FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS. IN ADDITION-
BUSINESS TO A BUSINESS PROWESS
JANE WAS DEEPLY ENGAGED WITH
VALLEY COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
AND CIVIC INSTITUTIONS TO NAME
JUST A FEW. HE SERVED ON THE
BOARD OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
MUSEUM OF NATURAL HISTORY SHE
IS A BOARD MEMBER OF THE VALLEY
ECONOMIC ALLIANCE IS. THAT ALSO
THE VALLEY PRESBYTERIAN
HOSPITAL IN THE SALVATION ARMY
AND SHE WAS A FOUNDING MEMBER
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY'S
FIRST FIVE COMMISSION. EVEN
AMONG HER PEERS SENATORS SHE
WAS A TREMENDOUSLY TALENTED
LARGER THAN LIFE CHARACTER
WHOSE LIFE WAS FIT. FOR THE BIG
SCREEN. A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES
SHE WASN'T JUST A GIFTED
DESIGNER SHE DESIGNED THE
INTERIORS FOR TYPE. OF MOTOR
HOMES IT BECAME THE NUMBER ONE
CLASS NATIONWIDE. SHE JUST
DIDN'T PLAY GOLF SHE HAD TWO
HOLES IN ONE. INCLUDING AT THE
INFAMOUS SIX HOLD THREE OF YOUR
GOLF CLUB. MR TO MARKET. SHE
DIDN'T JUST FLY IN AIRPLANES
SHE WAS A LICENSED PILOT WHO
FLEW ACROSS THE COUNTRY. SHE
DIDN'T JUST DRIVE CARS SHE WAS
PART OF THE GALVAN RACE TEAM
THAT BROKE THE TWENTY FOUR HOUR
ENDURANCE RACE. LAND SPEED
RECORD. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX
SHE BECAME THE FIRST WOMAN EVER
TO WIN THE FERNANDO AWARD THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY'S HIGHEST
HONOR. FOR COMMUNITY
VOLUNTEERISM. EFFORTLESS GRACE.
UNPARALLELED WIT AND SINGULAR
DEVOTION TO OUR COMMUNITY MY
COMMUNITY WILL BE MISSED MORE
THAN ANY WORDS COULD EXPRESS.
JANE WHO ARE TRULY THE
HEARTBEAT OF THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY. JANE IS SURVIVED BY HER
SOUL MATE OR HUSBAND OF OVER
FIFTY YEARS BURT BUCHMAN HER
FIVE CHILDREN VERNON DUTIES
BRETT BRAD AND BOW AND TWELVE
GRANDCHILDREN PLEASE MEMBERS
JOIN ME INTO JOINING THE
MEMORY. THE INCREDIBLE JANE
BUCKMAN. THE CENTERS BERG
CENTER DRAWS A- THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TO JOIN TODAY
IN MEMORY OF JUSTICE CRUZ
REYNOSO THE FIRST LATINO
APPOINTED TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SUPREME COURT. DOES IT
ALSO WAS A HUMBLE PUBLIC
SERVANT WHO BROUGHT PROFOUND%
CHANGE TO THE LEGAL WORLD AND
OPEN DOORS FOR GENERATIONS OF
LATINOS AND LATINAS. BORN IN
BREA CALIFORNIA JUST AS RENO
ALSO GREW UP AS ONE OF ELEVEN
CHILDREN. AND FROM THE AGE OF
EIGHT WORKED AS A FARM WORKER
IN ORANGE GROVES IN CALIFORNIA
LIKE ME HIS FAMILY WERE MIGRANT
FARM WORKERS WENT AND ALSO WAS
SEVEN THE FAMILY MOVED TO A
BATTERY- OUTSIDE OF LA HABRA WE
ATTENDED WILSON GRAMMAR SCHOOL.
A RACIALLY SEGREGATED GRADE
SCHOOL FOR CHILDREN OF MEXICAN
DESCENT THE US POSTAL SERVICE
REFUSE TO PROVIDE FREE DELIVERY
SERVICE WITHIN THE BODY- EVEN
THOUGH. NON MINORITY FAMILIES
LIVING NEARBY HAD THE SERVICE
FOR YOU CIRCULATE A PETITION
DEMANDING THE SERVICE AND THERE
WAS A RESPONSE TO THE PETITION
AND BEGAN MAIL DELIVERY HE ALSO
CHALLENGED THE LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARD ORGANIZED AROUND IT AND
THE GRAMMAR SCHOOL HE ATTENDED
WAS DESEGREGATED. SO IT WAS
FROM AN EARLY AGE IT WAS CLEAR
THE JUDGE GARLAND ALSO WAS
DESTINED FOR A LIFE MAKING A
DIFFERENCE AFTER RECEIVED HIS
UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE FROM
POMONA COLLEGE HE JOINED THE U.
S. ARMY SERVING IN THE COUNTER
INTEL INTELLIGENCE CORPS FOR
TWO YEARS HE WENT ON TO LAW
SCHOOL AT BERKELEY SCHOOL OF
LAW. AND THEN WENT ON TO STUDY
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW AT THE
NATIONAL UNIVERSITY OF MEXICO
HE ROSE TO PROMINENCE AS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE OR HE
HELPED RULE COMMUNITIES MADE UP
PRIMARILY. OF FARMWORKERS FROM
MEXICO LIKE HIS OWN PARENTS
DURING HIS TENURE AT THE C.
EARLY THE ONE CASES LIKE DIANA
VERSUS CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION A CASE AGAINSTTHE
STATE FOR LABOR LABELING LIKE
LATINO CHILDREN AS MENTALLY.
HANDICAPPED WHEN THEY WERE SENT
PLEASE NEW IN LEARN. WITH HIS
LEADERSHIP CAL AND THIS PRO. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO BROWN
APPOINTED AND ALSO TO THE STATE
SUPREME COURT HE SECURED
SIGNIFICANT VICTORIES UP
LIFTING THE RIGHTS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. PART OF THIS WAS
THE RULING ON NON ENGLISH
SPEAKING DEFENDANTS HAD TO BE
PROVIDED WITH INTERPRETERS AT
EVERY PHASE OF THE CRIMINAL
PROC PROCESS HE WAS THE TARGET.
OF APOLITICALLY CHARGED A
RECALL CAMPAIGN ALONG WITH TWO
OTHER JUSTICES AS QUOTE UNQUOTE
TOO SOFT ON CRIME. ALL THREE
JUDGES WERE RECALLED. AFTER HIS
SERVICE ON CALIFORNIA'S HIGHEST
COURT HE RETURNED TO PRACTICE
PRIOR PRACTICED AND TAUGHT AT
UCLA AND UC DAVIS HE WAS
FEATURED IN A DOCUMENTARY FILM
CALLED THE SOWING THE SEEDS OF
JUSTICE WHICH I RECOMMEND
YOU'LL WATCH. HIS CAREER HELPED
TO SHAPE A MORE COMPASSIONATE
LEGAL SYSTEM AND WE'RE ALL
BETTER OFF FOR IT HE WAS A
PERSONAL INSPIRATION FOR ME TO
PURSUE  LAW DEGREE AND PUT
SKILLS TO USE IN DEFENSE OF
WORKING PEOPLE. GET THIS
CONCERT AND BUS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR DRAWS OF
SENATOR NIELSEN ON THIS ITEM
SENATOR NELSON. LADIES AND- THE
SENATE BY HOSTING CALLING FROM
LOS IS TALKED ABOUT THE PUBLIC
CRUISE RENAULT CELL. AND I'M
PRIVILEGED TO HAVE A LITTLE
INSIGHT AS TO THE PERSONAL CRUZ
REYNOSO. HE WAS A CONSTITUENT.
BUT MORE THAN THAT THERE WAS A
CONNECTION. THROUGH HIS
GRANDSON. AN EMPLOYEE OF MINE.
STEPHEN HAYTER AS FAMILY HAIL
FROM EVIL CATTY. HIS MOTHER WAS
THE DAUGHTER OF JUSTICE RENAULT
SO. IT DOES DRIVE VISIT WITH
THEM IN THE AFTERMATH OF HIS
PASSING AND- REFLECTED WITH
THEM ON HIS LIFE. THEY SPOKE SO
FONDLY OF DIESEL AND- HOW HE
MADE ALL OF THE HOLIDAYS
SPECIAL HE FORGOT NONE OF THE-
THEY TALKED ABOUT THE FOURTH OF
JULY IN THE FLAGS THAT HE WOULD
BRING AND THEY WOULD GO ON FOR.
AT THEIR CELEBRATION. THE
MARCHERS THE CAMPING. TRIPS THE
DAY TOOK TOGETHER AS FAMILY.
IT'S CLEAR THAT THEY- ARE. A
VERY CLOSE FAMILY. AND THOUGH
THIS MAN HAD A VERY LARGE
PUBLIC LIFE. THE DEDICATED SO
VERY MUCH OF HIS LIFE. TO THOSE
PUBLIC ENDEAVORS THOSE GOOD
DEEDS THAT THE LORD WILL FAVOR
HAMEL FOR. AND HAVEN'T. HE DID
NOT NEGLECT HIS FAMILY. THEY
WERE CLOSE THEY LOVED HIM IT
WAS VERY EVIDENT FROM THEIR
WORDS AND THEIR EMOTIONS THAT
THEY LOVED HIM. I WOULD SAY
THAT JUSTICE FOR NO SO
SUCCEEDED IN ALL ASPECTS OF
LIFE. MAY BE WITH THE LORD.
THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON
SENATOR UMBERG ON THIS ITEM. MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES IT IS THE
LAST THREE TWO OF THE LIFE AND
CHARACTER OF JUSTICE FOR AND
ALSO THAT WE SHOULD HAVE A
DIVERSITY OF OUR COLLEAGUES WHO
SHOULD SPEAK IN RECOGNITION OF
HIS LIFE MY COLLEAGUE FROM TO
HAMMER MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES- I WANTED AS THE CHAIR
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IS MEMBER
THE PROFESSION- TO RECOGNIZE A
FELLOW ORANGE COUNTY IN. IS BY
COLLEAGUES HAVE MENTIONED-
JUSTICE RENAULT ALSO WAS A
TRAILBLAZER IN IN MANY
RESPECTS. IN PUBLIC SERVICE IN
LAW. IN IN MENTORING OTHERS- HE
WAS BORN IN BREA ORANGE COUNTY
NINETEEN THIRTY ONE HE WAS
REPATRIATED TO MEXICO AT AGE
ONE. IN OTHER WORDS ALTHOUGH
BORN HERE IN THE UNITED STATES
HE WAS SENT BACK TO MEXICO
WHERE HE ATTENDED. SCHOOLS AND
WORRY SAW THE ESSENTIAL DENIAL
OF PUBLIC SERVICES THAT HE
FOUGHT TO BRING BACK TO HIS-
KINFOLK HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES- THESE EXPERIENCES
SHAPED HIS WORLDVIEW IS CAREER
AND ULTIMATELY. AS MENTIONED
THE RECEIVED HIS LAW DEGREE
FROM UC BERKELEY A SCHOOL LAW
AND THEN RATHER THAN GOING TO
LOS ANGELES SAN FRANCISCO OR
NEW YORK AS HIS COLLEAGUES
WOULD DO. IN LAW SCHOOL HE WENT
TO THE IMPERIAL VALLEY WE
WORKED PROVIDE LEGAL SERVICES
TO MARGINALIZED CALIFORNIANS
SPECIALLY WOULD SERVE AS THE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA LEGAL
AURORA LEGAL ASSISTANCE- AND HE
SERVED IT DURING A TIME WHEN
GOVERNOR REAGAN TRIED TO BLOCK
FEDERAL FUNDING AND HE FOUGHT
IT AND THEN SUCCEEDED- HE
GUIDED C. R. L. A. THROUGH
SUCCESSFUL APPEAL OF GOVERNOR
REAGAN'S DECISION. RESULTED IN
A FEDERAL COMMISSION AFFIRMING
THAT THE VETO FUNDS WAS
UNJUSTIFIED AND C. R. L. A. WAS
A MODEL FIRM THAT PROVIDED
HIGHLY COMPETENT EFFICIENT AND
EXEMPLARY SERVICES TO
CALIFORNIANS. DEFENDING THE
ZERO EIGHT IT WAS SIGNIFICANT
BECAUSE GIVE FARM WORKERS AND
THE RULE FOLKS WHO LIVE IN
RURAL CALIFORNIA. POOR POOR
ACCESS TO ATTORNEYS AND LEGAL
PROTECTION. AS YOU KNOW
GOVERNOR BROWN APPOINTED
JUSTICE RENAULT SO THE
CALIFORNIA COURT OF APPEAL AND
THEN TO THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT. WHILE HE WAS ON THE
BENCH HE BROUGHT A UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE AND GAVE VOICE TO
CALIFORNIA'S MARGINALIZED-COMMUNITIES JUST AS RENAULT
ALSO. AUTHORED LANDMARK
DECISIONS EXPANDED ACCESS TO
JUSTICE INCLUDING DECISION AS
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
POINT OUT THAT ENSURE THAT NON
ENGLISH SPEAKING DEFENDANTS HAD
ACCESS TO AN INTERPRETER.
DURING COURT PROCEEDINGS WHICH
SEEMS AMAZING TO US BUT HE LED
THE WAY IN THAT RESPECT. AFTER
LEAVING THE SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE RENAULT ALSO RETURNED
TO PRIVATE PRACTICE PUBLIC
SERVICE AND ACADEMIA. HE SPENT
TWO DECADES MENTORING TEACHING
AND INSPIRING THE NEXT
GENERATIONS OF LAWYERS AT UCLA
AND UC DAVIS. SERVED AS THE
VICE CHAIRMAN OF THE U. S.
COMMISSION ON CIVIL RIGHTS WAS
AN ADVISER TO PRESIDENTS AND
RECEIVE THE PRESTIGIOUS
PRESIDENTIAL MEDAL OF FREEDOM.
JASON ALSO TOOK A PARTICULAR
INTERESTIN EXPANDING THE
PIPELINE OF YOUNG ADVOCATES OF
COLOR ENTERING THE LEGAL
PROFESSION AND OTHER YOUNG
ADVOCATES ONCE UPON A TIME I
WAS A YOUNG LAWYER AND- HAD A
VERY PLEASANT EXPERIENCE WITH
JUST ANOTHER BECAUSE HE WAS
INTERESTED IN ALL PEOPLE. AND
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO WERE.
JUST KNEW IN THE PROFESSION- HE
SHOULD TAKE CREDIT FOR MUCH
PROGRESS IN CALIFORNIA BUT AS A
HUMBLE PERSON HE DID NOT AND
WOULD NOT- HE HAD WONDERFUL
STORIES QUICK WIT CHARM GRACE
PASSION HUMILITY INSPIRED
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
YOUNG PEOPLE TO EXERCISE THEIR
PASSION WHETHER IN LAW OR OTHER
QUICK TO REMIND US THAT SO MUCH
MORE IS YET TO BE DONE HE
UNDERSTOOD FROM LIVED
EXPERIENCE THAT JUSTICE IS NOT
AN ABSTRACT CONCEPT BUT
SOMETHING THAT SHAPED EVERYDAY
THAT SHAPED EVERY DAY AND EVERY
INTERACTION PEOPLE HAVE WITH
THE LAW. HE WOULD HAVE URGES TO
GO FURTHER ENSURING THAT THE
LEGAL PROFESSION ADEQUATELY
REPRESENTS THE FULL DIVERSITY
AND POTENTIAL THAT OURS IS OUR
STATE'S READ RICHEST ASSET
COLLEAGUES I. S. THAT YOU
JOINED IN RECOGNIZING THE LIFE
AND SERVICE OF JUST SCREWS AND
ALSO THANK YOU THANK YOU SERRA
VIRGIE CENTER HURTS BURKE
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR GLAZER
CENTERS FOR. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT TO JOIN WITH MY
COLLEAGUES- JUSTICE AND ALSO
WAS A FRIEND OF MINE. HE IS A
FELLOW WHO OFTEN WHEN I HAD A
THORNY LEGAL PROBLEM THE PICK
UP THE PHONE AND HE WAS CALM
GRACIOUS VOICE. SCREEN OR ELECT
TO HELP ME FIGURE IT OUT. WE
SPENT A YEAR AND A HALF WORKING
TOGETHER ON INITIATIVE REFORM.
WITH THE THINK LONG COMMITTEE
OF CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA
FORD IN THE IRVINE FOUNDATION.
AND HE WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
PROVIDING THAT LAW. AND
THINKING IT THROUGH. THIS
FELLOW WHO. R. I. A. BEEN TO A
LOT OF CEREMONIES WE SWORN
ALONG THE YOUNG LAWYERS. AND A
GOOD FRIEND OF MINE TOM GREGO
WHO'S NOW JUDGE. THE TIME HE
WAS BEING SWORN IN AS A LAWYER
AND HIS FIRST TIME I SAW THIS
BEING DONE. JUSTICE YOU KNOW SO
WOULD PULL OUT BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE SIX ZERO SIX
EIGHT. AND HE WOULD READ THAT
CODE OUT LOUD AND REMIND THEN
TOM GRAY GO IN SINCE OTHERS AND
I HAVE. EMBARKED ON THAT
PRACTICE JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO
REFERENCING JUSTICE. READ ALSO
IN STREET. READ THE L. THE
PROVISION OF THAT BECAUSE WHICH
I READ HERE NOW. THE ONE
SENTENCE THAT WAS PRETTY IN
THAT HE EVERY NEW ALLOY. TO
EXPRESS OB. IS BEING A LAWYER.
AND THAT PROVIDES SECTION H.
SAYS NEVER TO REJECT IT IS THE
DUTY OF AN ATTORNEY TO DO ALL
OF THE FOLLOWING EACH. NEVER TO
BE CHECKED FOR ANY
CONSIDERATION PERSONAL TO
HIMSELF OR HERSELF THE CAUSE OF
THE DEFENSELESS OR THE-
PRESSED. AS HE TOOK AND GAVE
THE OATH OF OFFICE TO EVERY NEW
LAWYER HE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT EACH IN THIS HAD THAT SEED
IN THEIR MIND. AND I TOOK THAT
GUIDANCE FROM HIM AND HAVE DONE
THE VERY SAME THING EACH TIME
LITERALLY TWO WEEKS AGO IN HIS
NAME I WANT TO ADJOURN HIS
MEMORY HE IS A GREAT. GREAT
GREAT CUT CONTRIBUTE TO
CALIFORNIA AND A GREAT HUMAN
BEING. THANK YOU SIR HERS BERG
SENATOR GLAZER. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS- I HAD THE
DEEP HONOR OF WORKING WITHTHEM
FOR JUST THREE NOW SO- BEGAN IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE DURING A
VERY VERY DIFFICULT PERIOD.
WITH THE COURT UNDER SIEGE. THE
INDEPENDENCE OF THE JUDICIARY
UNDER SIEGE- AND JUSTICE RIGHT
NOW SO ALONG WITH HIS
COLLEAGUES ON THE COURT- UNDER
SERIOUS RECONFIRMATION.
ELECTION AND EVEN DURING THE
PRESSURES OF THAT MOMENT- HE
EXUDED AT SUCH A CALMNESS OF
HIS PLACE IN LIFE AND- IN
CIRCUMSTANCE BECAUSE HE KNEW
THAT HE HAD. DONE EVERYTHING
THE RIGHT WAY. AND THAT HE HAD
FULFILLED HIS OBLIGATIONS WITH
INTEGRITY. AND WITH
INDEPENDENCE AND THAT THE
POLITICAL WINDS OF THE DAY.
DIDN'T DRIVE HIS INSISTENCE ON
FOLLOWING HER JUSTICE WOULD
LEAD. ONE OF THE- MANY UNTOLD
STORIES OF THAT TIME- WAS AS
ELECTION DAY APPROACHED. AND IT
WAS CLEAR THAT HI CHIEF JUSTICE
ROSE LIZABETH BIRD WAS NOT
GOING TO BE CONFIRMED THAT SHE
TOOK HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS FROM HER ACCOUNTS AND
GAVE IT TO JUSTICE RIGHT NOW SO
THAT HIS VOICE COULD STILL BE
HEARD- AT THE END OF THAT VERY
DIFFICULT. PROCESS HE WAS A
TRAILBLAZER AND YOU WOULDN'T
KNOW IT BY HIS DEMEANOR. HE
EXHIBITED SUCH HUMILITY AND THE
WORK THAT HE WAS DOING. BUT HE
WAS A PROFOUND. TRAILBLAZER FOR
OUR STATE AND FOR SO MANY OF US
WHO ADMIRED HIS SERVICE. AND HE
WILL BE DEEPLY DEEPLY MESSED
AND IT IS MY HOPE IS WE
RECOGNIZE HIM AT HIS SERVICE
THAT WE AS LEADERS IN THIS
STATE CAN FIND OPPORTUNITIES TO
RECOGNIZE SUCH GREAT. MEN AND
WOMEN AS JUSTICE RIGHT NOW SO
IN THE WORKINGS OF OUR STATE.
HE IS DESERVING OF GREAT
THE MEMORY THAT WE REFLECT ON
HERE TODAY CAN CONTINUE ON WITH
A RECOGNITION OF HIS NAME IN
PLACES OF OUR WNDERFUL GOLDEN
STATE. AND WITH THAT I. PAST
THAT WE ADJOURN IT IS WONDERFUL
MEMORIES. THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZER THIS- INS ARE GERMAN
MEMORIES MEMBERS IF YOU CAN
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES FORWARD
TO THE DESK SO THAT THEY CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
SENATE- IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS. SENATOR BATES THE
DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT THE FINISH WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE WE WILL
RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO PM HAVE
A GREAT WEEKEND THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES THE SENATE IS IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT
WHICH TIME THE GERMAN MOTION
WILL BE MADE WE WILL RE KEEP%
RECONVENE ON MONDAY. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AT TWO PM THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE TODAY.